الله يغفر الوالد كان له مثل يقول
مليون في دربه ولا ريال في غير دربه
تعالوا نبي ننظم المطبخ
ونحوله من مركز تكلفه الى مركز ربح صارت
تجينا الضغوط انه افتحوا لنا ارسلوننا
وبندفع فلوس تكفون
ماطرينا فعلا نفتح لبعض الاصدقاء والاقارب
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه وانا عمر
الجريسي استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال
وقاده الراي ضيف حلقه اليوم هو الاستاذ
عبد العزيز بن محمد السبيعي عضو مجلس
اداره شركه ماسك
الشركه اللي تعتبر نموذج حبينا اننا نركز
عليه ونتوسع فيه لحوكمه وتنظيم الشركات
العائليه 80% من الشركات في السعوديه
شركات عائليه المعلومه الاهم 90% من
الشركات العائليه تنهار بعد الجيل الثاني
وهذه خساره اقتصاديه هائله جدا فتجربه
ماسك كانت جدا مشجعه في كيف تنظيم وترتيب
العمل العائلي يحافظ على العلاقات الاسريه
يعظم الثروه العائليه وذكرناها بالارقام
ويساعد على عمل خيري مستدام ويرتب الشؤون
العائليه كل هذه كانت محاور حلقتنا واللي
ختمنا فيها في النهايه بوصفه يوصي بها
ضيفنا لكل من هو مهتم بهذا الشان احنا
اليوم في مرحله تح ول اقتصادي العديد من
الشركات قاعده تتاسس والعديد من الشركات
قاعده تتحول فمهم انها تراعي مثل هذه
الوصفه لتبني شركه تستمر مئه عام واكثر
باذن الله اترككم مع الحوار
حياك الله ابو خالد شرفت ونورتنا شكرا ابو
عبد الرحمن انا شاكر لك على الاستضافه
والحقيقه يعني ان شاء الله نتمنى نقدم شيء
يكون مفيد انا متاكد اسفين على سويناه في
المكتب
بشكل كبير ما ادري ايش سويتوا يعني وين
المكتب اصلا وين اللي اخوي ابراهيم رئيس
مجلس ما هو موجود ولا كان حاسب على حساب
مين ومين اللي جاء ومين اللي شال وتشرد
التكاليف كلها علي الله
لا والله احنا
ممتنين
وشاكرين لك صراحه
القبوله الدعوه يعني يلا جت الموافقه وانت
مكل في الظهور وش السبب والله يا ابو عبد
الرحمن جزء منها ثقافه العائله تعرف الله
يغفرله ويرحم الوالد كان
من القيم اللي يعتنقها في العمل هو يعني
عدم الظهور الاعلامي
والاسباب كثيره يعني صراحه وانا واخواني
واخواتي يعني والعائله بشكل عام مقتنعين
بهالاسباب صراحه فعلا مفيده يعني الظهور
الاعلامي تعرف سلاح ذو حدين
وطبيعه عمل البزنس فيها اخطاء وفي مناطق
رماديه كثير
فيعني ظهور الاعلامي قد يسبب لك مشاكل انت
بس انا اشكرك انك يعني قبلت هذا الاستثناء
وظهرت معانا للمصلحه العامه كانت دافع
صراحه ما هو الحديث عن تجربه تجربه تجاريه
ما هو هو محور تركيز اساسا اصلا هذا مو
بتركيز بودكاستقراض لكن التركيز هو على
تجربه الكوكب تجربه ماسسه العمل والانتقال
من جيل الى جيل واللي هي دائما تكون معضله
في الشركات العائليه يعني احنا يمكن عندنا
رقمين مرعبه
اذا اخذناهم مع بعض الرقم الاول انه حدود
80% من الشركات في السعوديه هي شركات
عائليه وهذا نسبه قريبه حتى من اللي في
العالم
النسبه الثانيه المرعبه مع هذه النسبه هي
انه اكثر من 88 او 90% من الشركات
العائليه في العالم تنهار في الجيل الثالث
وهذا يعني هدره خساره اقتصاديه غير عاديه
فالاصل هو فلاء الشركات العائليه
الاستثناء والقله هم اللي يقدروا يلقون
الوصفه حقت الاستمرار فانتم القله اللي
عندكم تجربه رهيبه في هذا الجانب وانت كنت
تقود هذا المشروع من 2011 او 2010 فيها
فكان هذا محور الحلقه فنشكر لك يعني قبوله
الدعوه ونشكر العائله يعني قبولها انك انت
تظهر لانه هذا يخالف سياستكم لكن في مصلحه
عامه من مشاركه التجربه والله بكل امانه
انما يعني اخذت استاذنت العائله في الظهور
ما اخفيك
الاغلبيه بسيطه صراحه وافقه بس في في جزء
كبير كان معارض زي ما قلت لك لانه هذا
مخالف للسياساتنا لكن انت هزيتني في كلمه
صراحه قلتها وهذي اللي خلاني ارجع واحارب
واقنعهم واقول لهم الا لازم نظهر يوم قلت
لي انت انه ترى امانه في رقبتكم اي والله
انكم تشاركون التجارب بسلبياتها
وبايجابياتها مع العوائل لانه فعلا زي ما
تفضلت انه يعني كثير من العوائم بحاجه الى
انها تعرف وش الاساليب الشغل انا ما اقول
انه اللي سويناه في ماسك مناسب لكل
العوائل
مناسب لنا وفي اشياء قد لا تكون مناسبه
لغيرنا لكن بكل امانه يعني
هذا السبب الاساسي لظهوري اليوم واشكر
اخواني واخواتي صراحه اللي سمحوا لي يعني
بالظهور واتمنى انك ما تسال اسئله حساسه
تزعلهم مني خليهم
انا متاكد بس بشيل النقطه ترى بامانه
المشروع ما هو مشروعي يعني انت قلت انه
انت كنت تقود المشروع انا والله ما كنت
اقود المشروع انت بتستغرب يمكن من هالكلام
وبندخل في التفاصيل يعني المشروع صراحه
يمكن قادوا رؤيه الوالد الله يرحمه بس
الاهم هو اتحاد الابناء والبنات ورغبتهم
القويه في انهم يبقون مع بعض
وبالذات البنات انا اقول لك اخواتي البنات
انا فخور انتم ثلاثه اولاد وسبع بنات احنا
ثلاثه اولاد وسبع بنات
وما ابالغ اذا قلت لك انه صراحه سبب اليوم
وصولنا لهالرحله بشكل كبير صراحه يعود
للبنات ليش
واذا تبغى ندخل التفاصيل ليش لان البنات
امنوا بهذا المشروع وهم برا الشركه
احنا العيال كنا داخلين وشايفين وعارفين
ومستمتعين بالعمل
البنات ما كان تعرفي فتره من الفترات ما
كان في اي شفافيه وهذا العرف في اغلب
شركات العائليه ولا كان في اي يعني مشاركه
لاي معلومات ولا كان في مشاركه لهم في
اتخاذ القرار الوالد كان يعني يدير واحنا
معه وماشيه الامور
فامنوا بدون ما يكونون داخلين الشركه
والحمد لله اقول لك هذا سبب اساسي في
اليوم للي وصلت لماسك بكل امانه وهذي اللي
حتكون محور الاساسي لحلقتنا موضوع تجربتكم
في الحوكمه والخطوات اللي مريتوا فيها بس
قبلها خلينا يعني نستعرض بشكل سريع تاريخ
الاسره التجاري بس عشان اللي ما هو عارف
او او يعني كشركه بروفايل او او يعني ما
تحب ظهور اعلامي يمكن مو بالكل يعرف اشياء
ماسك خلينا نذكر بشكل سريع تجربه العم
محمد الله يرحمه شلون بدات اهم المحطات
وبعدين نوصل لموضوع الحوكمه والفصل بين
العم محمد والعم عبد الله الله يرحمهم
الوالد بدا في العمل التجاري طبعا تعرف
الولد مولود في عنيزه
وتوفى والده وهو عمره 11 سنه
واضطر انه
يسافر لمكه طلبا للرزق وهم 11 سنه بيروح
يعني طلع من النيجر راح لمكه يشتغل مع ام
ناصر
واشتغل فيه مهن يعني الدنيا كثير قبل ما
صراحه يؤسس اول
عمل تجاري كان بالشراكه مع العم سليمان
الغنيم الله يغفر له ويرحمه
[موسيقى]
بعدها انضم له العم عبد الله يعني احتاج
الى مساعده وانضمنو لعم عبد الله لو اخوه
الاصغر اخوه الاصغر نعم جابهم من من عنيزه
واستقروا في مكه معه وانضم له في العمل
والشراكه مع العم سليمان كانت على ثلاثه
شهور هي واستمرت 30 سنه
بعد بعد ما انتهت الشراكه بيننا وبين
سليمان الغيم استمرت الشراكه بين الوالد
والعم عبد الله وصار التركيز هنا على
الموضوع الصرافه والبانكن
والقطاع المتركزي على القطاع المالي
والعقاري جت في مرحله لاحقه
وهذه كانت احنا نتكلم على طفره السبعينات
الثمانينات اللي كان فيها صحيح انتوا
كنتوا يعني او العم محمد كان
وش يسمى يعني الدكان صرافه ولا بنك ما
كانت بنو كان مصرف كان شركه محمد وعبد
الله للصرافه هذا اللي عرفت فيه ومنشهرت
فيه الاسره في زي ما تفضلت من السبعينات
وطالع وهذا كان محور العمل العائلي وخلني
اقول لك الاساس او القاعده اللي انطلقت
منها
نشاط تجاري في ايرادات ومداخيل جيده هذه
المداخيل تعيدون استثمارها في القطاع
العقاري فبنى يعني محفظه عقاريه صحيح هي
اللي ممكن نمت الثروه بشكل اقصد صدق جت
لحظه يعني متقدمه في في يعني 2009 2010
صحيح في ذيك المراحل
قررت الفصل
اعطنا كواليس شلون وصلتوا لتلك اللحظه
وشلون سويتوها
يعني في عام 2010 كان قرار الفصل الوالد
والعم
اكتشفوا انه
يعني الافضل يكون في استقلاليه في
ملكيه العمل التجاري بين الطرفين
ويمكن لو تسالني بكل امانه وش السبب
الرئيسي لهذا القرار اللي يمكن
يعني ما كان متوقع ما اخفيك يعني
احنا كنا متعودين وعلاقه الوالد بالعلم
ترى علاقه قويه جدا وانا وعيال عمي
واخواتي وبنات عمي ترانا اسره واحده يعني
وتعرف في بيننا نسب وبيننا ذكريات جميله
والطفوله وبينه لكن لو تسالني وش السبب
اللي خلانا نوصل للمرحله
وهذا يمكن يخلينا ناخذ قرار مصيري ايضا في
في تنظيمنا هو دخول الابناء
في العمل العائلي الجيل الثاني الجيل
الثاني اثناء محمد وابناء عبد الله بالضبط
احنا ويمكن دخولنا كان حتى بطريقه يمكن من
انا بالنسبه لي انه من اسوا الطرق يعني في
طرق يمكن افضل بكثير لدخول الابناء
والبنات في العمل العائلي لكن يمكن
الطريقه اللي كنا شغالين فيها اول او كنا
نشتغل فيها اول ما كانت ابدا
هي الطريقه الصحيحه يعني شلون
كانت مقسمه الى اما مناطق او قطاعات وكل
ولد مسؤول عن يا منطقه يا قطاع
فهذه شويه سببت تعرف لما تكون انت في
منطقه معناته انت لك علاقه بالمسؤول عن
القطاع وفي نفس الوقت
الصلاحيات ما كانت واضحه والمسؤوليات ما
كانت واضحه فكان في كثير من خلني اقول لك
يعني الشد في الجانب التجاري اللي في ذيك
اللحظه لاحظنا انه بدا ياثر على العلاقه
العائليه لذلك الوالد العم اخذوه قرار
مصيري قالوا ما دام وصلنا للمرحله خلونا
نحافظ على العلاقه العائليه
ونفصل العمل وهذا زي ما انت فضلت كثير من
القطاع العوائل توصل للمرحله للاسف يعني
وهذا يمكن ابو خالد هنا نوقف يعني شوي قبل
ما نكمل قصه ونفتح سالفه اسباب فشل
الشركات العائليه اللي انا اتذكر اخذت
كورس فيها وطلعت على الاسباب كان يمكن من
اشهر ثلاث اسباب
رقم واحد
اختلاف رؤيه الجيل الثاني مقارنه مع الجيل
الاول يعني الجيل الاول هم بداوا في ظروف
وبيئه وفرص مختلفه واسسوا يجي الجيل
الثاني عنده رؤيه مختلفه عنده فرص مختلفه
عنده ظروف مختلفه فيبغى يتجه اتجاه اخر ما
يلقى نفسه قادر على هذا الاتجاه فيحدث
الانقسام والاختلاف يمكن واحده من اهم
اسباب سقوط شركه عاليه انه الجيل الثاني
ياتي برؤيه مختلفه بس ما يمكن من تحقيقها
وهذا قد يكون جزء من اللي انتم مريتوا فيه
سبب ثاني هو الدخول المفاجئ
للبنات وابناء البنات اللي هم عاده في
الشركات العائليه مهمشين مبعدين ما هم ما
هم جزء من العمل التنفيذي لانه طبيعه
الثقافه المحليه اللي يعملون هم الابناء
وليس البنات هذا الاصل او هذا العرف
السائد السبب الثالث هو انه في كثير من
الحالات يكون النجاح
مبني على الجهد خارق من المؤسس سخر
علاقاته سخر قدرات اسخر امكانياته وصنع
قصه ممتازه لكنه لا ينجح في توريث هذه
العلاقات وورث اصول وورث الشركات لكن ما
ورث العلاقات ما ورث
الخبره اللي صنعها في في اثناء براء هذه
الشركه فهل تقدر تسولفنا شوي عن اسباب فشل
الشركات العائليه اذا سواء الاسباب هذه او
اذا في اسباب اضافيه انت قلتها ما شاء
الله عليك الاسباب اللي قلتها مئه بالمئه
يعني فعلا هي سبب كبير بس في سبب
يعني يكون ايضا
مهم جدا وهو دخول الانساب لا تنسى في
الجيل الثاني والجيل الثالث كلمه الانساب
عاد تكون يعني قويه في القرار
للاطراف من خارج العائله اللي هم زوجات
الاولاد وازواج البنات يعني
ايضا يعني
قضيه مهمه جدا يمكن عندنا في المملكه
بالذات زي ما تفضلت دخول المراه في العمل
وفي وبالذات في منطقتنا يعني في نجد يعني
يمكن المنطقه الشرقيه والمنطقه الغربيه
السابقين صراحه الموضوع
وهذا كان صراحه يسبب اشكال في الشفافيه
ووصول المعلومات مو بس البنات لابناء
البنات اللي هم يعتبرون يعني احيانا بعضهم
تلقاهم ناجحين في اعمالهم وقاده في لكن ما
يحصلون على وهذا يؤدي الى انه يعني
الالتزام تجاه الشركه العائليه يكون اقل
بكثير وهذه ظروف اللي كانت تحيط
بوضع شركتكم احنا نتكلم على وقتها شركه
كانت تحولت الى بنك بنك البلاد ولا لا
تحول الى بنك البلاد
اللي هو القطاع الصرافه فقط الصرافه فقط
الصرافه هو اللي تم تقييمه ودخلنا مع عده
صرافين في ذاك الوقت
وتحول الى بنك البلاد اما باقي
القطاعات لا زالت عائليه عائليه
اتذكر انت قلت لي حوار صار بينك وبين
والدك الله يرحمه في مساله الفصل
وذكر مصطلح محدد ابي اسمع منك عطنا كواليس
الفصل
الوالد يعني لما جاء يعني موضوع الفصل
كان يعني زي ما قلت لك يعني تاخذ القرار
على مضض يعني وكان شايف يعني انه الامور
يعني قد اذا لم يتخذ فيها قرار حاسم في
ذاك اللحظه قد يعني تسوء الى ما هو اسوا
لكن كانت وصيته لنا صراحه انا واخواني لما
جاء تكلمنا في احد الجلسات في موضوع الفصل
قال انا ما عندي مانع لكن ارجوكم رجاء
تكونون مع بعض انتم واخواتكم
ولازم تشوفون طريقه كيف انه
الشركه هذه تستمر
ويعني كانت نظرته هو لهالموضوع انه فعلا
الاتحاد قوه ودائما لما تتفرق الاسره
تجد الضعيف
ينتهي بسرعه يعني وهذا ما كان يبغى يصير
يعني كان يبغى كان يقول يتعلمه من اللي
صار لي انا واخوي
ترتيباتكم نعم انا انا واخوي يعني سوينا
اللي سويناه وبنينا الشركه هذه لسنوات
طويله والحمد لله نمت وتطورت فكان يبغى
نفس الكلام هذا يستمر مع الجيل الثاني
وتفاجئنا هذا اللي انا صراحه يعني
تفاجانا انه عشان يحقق الرؤيه
وهذا ما عرفناه الا بعد ما توفى الله
يرحمه في سنوات الاخيره يعني كان يعني
مريض كان
ندخل عليه في غرفته احيانا انه على السرير
وكذا ادخل عليه انا احيانا لحالي والبنات
لحالها واخواني الحال اذا صرنا لحالنا
يوصيني انا على البنات يقول انتبهوا عبد
العزيز انتبه لخواتك
وتفاجئنا انه لما تدخل البنت عليه في
الغرفه لحاله
لا تتركين اخوانك خليك مع اخوانك فشوف كيف
رؤيته كان له نظره وكان يستخدم كل الادوات
هذه لانجاحوا وهذا ترى انا ارجع نقطه اللي
قلت لك انا كيف دور البنات كان في في نجاح
اللي وصلنا له اتوقع هذا لحظات الحاسمه
والكلمات الحاسمه والوالد كان لها دور في
شخصيه مهمه في هالمرحله وانت ذكرته باشاده
وهو يستاهل الشخص لنا الراجحي ايش كان
دوره في المرحله هذه والله الشخص سليمان
العم سليمان الله يطول عمره ويحفظه طبعا
الوالد اول ما جينا ترى رفض رفض الفكره
يعني وكان الاخ ناصر يعني صراحه يعني قال
لا ابدا شوفوا حل مش ممكن يكون الفصل هو
الحل
فيعني في الاخير
الاخ ناصر كان يعني عضو مجلس اداره في
مصرف الراجحي قبل
وتعرف على علاقه بالعم سليمان والعمل
سليمان كان يعتبر الوالد بمثابه يعني اخ
واب في بعض الاحيان
وكان تعرف له قصص كثيره مع الوالد
وفي احد زياراته للوالد
يعني طرح هو فتح كان يسمع عن بعض يعني
التحديات اللي كانت موجوده
فسال ناصر
فكرته في موضوع الفصل وكذا قال له والله
احنا طرحنا الموضوع الوالد والولد رفض
الله يجزاه خير قال لا انا اللي بجيب
اكلمه وجاء فعلا عند الوالد وحكى له قصه
يعني فصلهم هو اخوانه وكيف انه الامور مشت
بشكل طبيعي والحمد لله تطورت والعلاقه
العائليه استمرت فكان له الله يجزاه خير
دور كبير في قناع الوالد في هذا الموضوع
صراحه
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
لما جيت للحظه يعني تنفيذ الفصل كان عند
والد توصيه في طريقه الفصل قال ابيها مثل
مثل قسمه البطيخ ايه قال ابدا انا ما عندي
مانع صحيح الوالد لما جاء وقت الفصل قال
انا ما عندي مانع وهذه كانت توصيته لناصر
لانه احنا اخترنا الاخ ناصر هو اللي يكون
يعني ممثلنا في العمليات الفصل فكان يعني
اوصل اخوي ناصر قال له ما عندي مانع في
الفصل لكن ابغاها تكون قسم البطيخ
تعرف مصطلح قسمه بطيخ عندنا فيها المقصود
فيها انك لا تركز على حجم البطيخ خلاص
وحده وحده لا تقعد تفصل وتركز وكذا يعني
خليكم سامحين سامحين في في الاجراءات كان
اخذ منكم الموضوع
والله ما اخذ اعتقد ثلاث شهور كان كل شيء
منتهي وكل شيء موقع وكل شيء
وتم بطريقه جدا جدا صراحه جميله يعني تخيل
انه مثلا
الاجراء اللي تم يعني طبعا تشكلت لجنه
فيها ممثل من كل طرف وكان في اثنين
مستقلين
واتفقوا على انه كل واحد اول شيء يحصلون
الاصول والثروه
بكل بنودها في الميزانيات انا قلت لك كنا
كل واحد كان مسؤول عن شيء وما كنا نعرف
الشيء اللي عند الطرف الاخر وهم يعرفون
اللي عندنا وكان فيه يعني شويه خلني اقول
نقص في موضوع الشفافيه
فقلنا خلنا نحصر كل شيء ثروه حصرنا كل شيء
بعدين طلب من كل طرف انه يقدم وايش
الاشياء اللي يرغب يحتفظ فيها
تكون مسكره بظرف مسكر وتم تكليف الاعضاء
المستقلين بانهم يشوفون الاشياء اللي كل
طرف يرغب في الاحتفاظ فيها طبعا كل شيء
مقيم وقيمنا كل شيء وكل شيء
كل الاشياء اللي راغب فيها عائله محمد
السبيعي اخذ وما يبغاها عائله ما طلبوها
عائله عبد الله اخذوها عائله محمد وكل
الاشياء اللي طلبوها عائله عبدالله وما
طلبوها عائله محمد اخذوها عائله محمد
اخذوها عائله عبدالله اسف والاشياء اللي
طلبت من الطرفين بالقرعه
الاجراء بالقرعه وخلاص يلا انت خذ هذا
والاشياء اللي ما طلبت هذه كانت هي
البلانس هي المرجح المرجح خلاص انت خذ هذه
اللي ما طلبت انت ناقص عن تقييم كذا ناقص
عن كذا فانت هذه ما طلبت خذها ونفس الشيء
يعني
فكانت صراحه
وتم توقيع ثلاثه شهور منتهي ويمكن يحسب
صراحه لكم
ويؤكد على على سماحه وصفاء النفوس في تلك
المرحله انه ما حذره صحيح ما حد درى لا
شفنا في اعلام ولا شفنا في صحف ولا شفنا
في اي محاكم ولا شفنا في اي يعني احنا
كاقصد كمجتمع ما سمعنا الا انه ترى تم
الفصل هذه احدى القيم الاساسيه ما يحب
الاعلام ذي انا متاكد لو كان
يعني البروفايل الاعلامي عالي كان الكل
درى والكل تدخل والكل كتب والكل يعني اثر
على تفكير ولو من افراد العائله احد يعني
يخالف هذه السياسه ولا عنده هوس الضجيج
الاعلامي والحضور اعلامي كان ممكن تحتاج
بس واحد
بعدها اللحظه اللي هي تقريبا 2010 2011
بداتوا رحلتكم في موضوع الحوكمه والماسسه
واللي هي لب حلقه اليوم فمن وين بديت ابو
خالد مش اول خطوه في حوكمه الشركات
العائليه والله شوف احنا الحقيقه بدينا
البدايه الصحيح الحقيقيه كانت قبل الفصل
يعني بكل امانه
كان الوالد والعم
وعيال العم والاخوان
يحسون بالضغط وان نحتاج الى تنظيم انا قلت
لك العلاقات كيف كانت والطريقه كيف كانت
فبصراحه بحثنا ولقينا في كورس في جامعه
انسياد في سنغافوره
يتكلم عن تنظيم الشركات العاليه وكان فيه
يعني بروفيسور
امريكي
وكان يتكلم عن كثير من التجارب في الشركات
الامريكيه والشركات اليابانيه والصينيه
وحتى الشركات بعض الشركات من المنطقه هنا
لها
يعني تنتقل من جيل لجيل وشركات منظمه
وعملها ناجح
ورحنا حضرت الكورس هذا انا واثنين من عيال
عمي الحقيقه وفعلا كان بالنسبه لي انا
شخصيا
فتح يعني زي ما تفضلتوا
موضوع تنظيم الشركات عاليه صندوق اسود
يحتاج الى تعمق يحتاج الى فهم
هو يحتاج انك تفصله على الاشياء التي
تناسب والاشياء اللي ما تناسب فكانت هذه
اول صراحه يعني مبادره او مبادره اللي
ساعدتنا كثير في اننا نفهم وشو اساسا وش
الشركه العائليه
وكيف تتنظم الاساسيات اللي هي البيسك
فبعدها لما رجعنا من الكورس هذا صراحه
شاركنا الكلام هذا مع الاخوان وعيال العم
واثنوا على انه فعلا يعني الكلام اللي
سمعوه قالوا ليش ما نجيب البروفيسور
يعطينا يوم كامل ورشه عمل ونتكلم فيه عن
الحاله حقتنا وش نسوي فعلا دعينا
البروفيسور
كارلوك الله يذكره بالخير وجاء وسوينا
ورشه عمل في جده يوم كامل وفعلا غصنا في
دهاليز لما كانت شركه محمد عبدالله
ابراهيم السبيعي
فكانت هذه صراحه البدايه وفعلا هنا بنيت
القناعه عند الجميع بانه نحتاج الى تنظيم
ولا نعرف شو مسوي لكن هنا التنظيم
طبعا جت مرحله الفصل وما كملنا صراحه
الرحله جت مرحله الفصل اللي هو 2010 وما
كمل الرحله
بعد 2010 بكل امانه
يعني تحقيق لرغبه الوالد اللي ذكرت لك
اياها قبل شوي ورغبه الاخوان والاخوات
كلهم الحقيقه
شكلنا لجنه
واشتغلنا يعني ورش عمل طويله صراحه مطوله
كانت مع احد المكاتب الاستشاريه
والبدايه هي في الميثاق العائلي يعني ابو
عبد الرحمن اليوم تعرف انت في الشركات في
دائرتين
دائره الملكيه
ودائره العمل التنفيذي او العمل الاداري
الدائرتين هذه متقاطعه بشكل جزئي
ودائره الملكيه عاده ليحكمها نظام وزاره
التجاره نظام هيئه سوق المال الانظمه
القضائيه الانظمه العليا في اي دوله
والمرجع فيها عاده لمؤسسات حكوميه
الدائره التنفيذ
اللي يحكمها نظام الحوكمه
والسياسات والاجراءات في الشركات ومرجعها
عاده الجمعيه العموميه في في الشركه
الشركات العاليه دائره ثالثه تجي وتتقاطع
معها الدائرتين هذه وتسبب تعقيد اكبر
واكبر اللي هي دائره العائله
طب دائره العائله وش اللي يحكمها
عاده مجموعه قيم غير مكتوبه هذا اللي
يحكمها مرجعها وشو عاده المؤسس او كبير
العائله
فاذا ما كتبت واذا ما نظمت هذه الدائره
وعلاقتها بدائره الملكيه وعلاقتها بدائره
التنفيذ هنا تبدا نقاط التماس ونقاط يعني
التحسس والمشاكل فلينظم
دائره العائله يا ابو عبد الرحمن هو
الميثاق العائلي
وذكر هنا ابو خالد قبل ما ندخل في موضوع
الميثاق
البروفيسور اللي دعيتوه كان يسال عن
اسالكم سؤال قال انتم موجودين عشان تختمون
الشركه ولا الشركه موجوده عشان تخدم هذا
كان سؤال جوهري واعتقد حركات البدايه
البدايات وهذا السؤال
يفترض ان يسال لكل شركه عائليه تبغى
التنظيم يعني
يعني قال
في الورشه في ورشه العمل هذا الكلام كم
كان في ورشه العمل وهذا كان من ضمن
الاشياء اللي اتفقت عليها كل العائله
هل العائله موجوده لدعم الشركه العائليه
ام الشركه العائليه موجوده لدعم العائله
وكان يشرح يعني يقول اذا انتم فعلا تموتون
تصنعون عمل عائلي فيجب على العائله ان
تدعم الشركه العائليه اما اذا كنتوا تبون
تسمعون جمعيه خيريه
فالشركه العائليه هي اللي
تدعم العائله
بصراحه كان اختيار بالاجماع انه لا
العائله موجوده لدعم الشركه العائليه وهذا
لا يعني ان الشركه العائليه لا تعطي فوائد
وتعطي دعم للعائله ولكن دعم منظم دعم
محوكم دعم ياخذ في الاعتبار
المصلحه العليا وياخذ في الاعتبار
الاهداف طويله الامد يعني ياخذ بالاعتبار
اشياء اخرى
وهذا اللي الحمد لله الشركات يعني
العائليه الناجحه اليوم قاعده تتمتع فيه
فاول خطوه كانت هي اعداد الميثاق وانت
عديتهم ميثاقكم الاول واعتمد في 2015 نعم
يعني اكرمتني نسخه منه واللي صراحه عجبني
في النسخه واللي هو قد يبدو للناس نقطه
ضعف انا اشوفها نقطه قوه انه المثال كان
بسيط وكان
ومباشر ولا فيه صراحه ما شفت اشياء مبهره
يعني ما شفت الاشياء اللي بقول واو كيف
سويتوها
مره كان مبسط فيبدو ان السياسه كانت خلونا
نبدا بهالنقطه ونطور لاحقا خلونا نوثق
اللي احنا متفقين عليه مبدئيا ونحسسه
ونطوره لاحقا فكتب الميثاق بمجموعه اركان
فيها تعريفات فيها طريقه التخارج فيها
طريقه حل النزاعات فيها طريقه الاداره
فيها هل الابناء يكونون في فريق التنفيذي
ولا ما يكونون
بغطى اغلب الاسئله اللي عاده ينتج عنها
مشكله اذا لم تغطى او تكتب فعطنا كواليس
كتابه الميثاق وايش توصيتك لليوم الشركات
اللي ما عندها ميثاق عائلي وش افضل طريقه
انهم ينجزون هذا الامر
سر النجاح دائما يا ابو عبد الرحمن وانت
قادره وانت ماشي في البساطه اليوم كل ما
كنت بسيط واضح ومباشر كان نجاحك اسهل
وكان نجاحك اوضح واسرع
يعني زي ما تفضلت الهدف من الميثاق
العائلي هو معالجه
خلنا نقول نقاط التماس الاساسيه لاعاده
تنتج عنها مشاكل مشاكل
اول
نقطه تماس يمكن هي موضوع الملكيه والتملك
كيف التملك
وكل القضايا لها علاقه بالملكيه وهذا كان
واضح في الميثاق
النقطه الثانيه طريقه اختيار مجلس الاداره
والاداره التنفيذيه
والاداره وكل ما يتعلق بالاداره
النقطه الثالثه
القرارات المتعلقه بتوزيع الارباح
والقرارات المتعلقه بالجمعيه العموميه
والنقطه الرابعه
قضايا النزاعات والخلافات ولو نشات وكيف
تعالج وكيف يتم يعني
الاجراءات في في في في معالجتها يعني فهذه
هذه هي اهم اربع قضايا في اي ميثاق عائلي
خلنا وحده في بعض العوائل يضيفون اشياء
ثانيه احنا ما راينا صراحه
اننا نروح على قولتهم لهذه المنطقه لان
فعلا نبغى نترك الحريه بكل امانه
يعني افراد العائله
يعني انهم ياخذون قرارات ايضا يعني قد لا
تكون مؤثره بشكل كبير على العمل العالي
وخصوصا وخصوصا نحن اخذنا قرار مصيري ابو
عبد الرحمن وكثير من العوائل يعني صراحه
اذا جلست اتكلم معهم يقولون انتم كيف
اخذتوا هالقرار وايش تاثيراته على
ابناء جيل المستقبل والقرار اللي اخذناه
انه
فصل الملكيه على الاداره بشكل كامل
وانه ابناء العائله لا يعملون في العمل
التنفيذي
اركز عليها بصراحه
قلت لك انا يمكن هذا ناتج عن
المشاكل التي العهد السابق اللي كان كنا
بدانا نحسها وكنت قلت لك هو كان سبب يمكن
اساسي في الفصل كنا حنا كلنا داخلين في
العمل انتم عيال عمكم احنا وعيال عمنا نعم
صحيح
يعني القرار اللي اتخذ
لا يعني
عدم دخول الابناء في او جيل المستقبل او
حتى احنا كجيل ثاني في العمل العائلي ولكن
دخولنا يكون فقط عن طريق مجال مجالس
الاداره
وكل شخص يرغب في ترشيح نفسه المجلس
الاداره يجب ان يخضع لمعايير معينه يجب ان
يحقق عده معايير مذكوره في الميثاق
وايضا عندنا مجلس اداره الشركه القابضه
وعندنا او الشركه العائليه وعندنا مجالس
ادارات في الشركات التابعه ايضا يمكن لاي
فرد من افراد العائله
ان يرشح نفسه بتوصيه طبعا المجلس اداره
الشركه القابضه
ايضا
في اداره التنفيذيه ونعرف يعني بعض
الاصدقاء اصدقائي من ابناء العائله واعرف
قديش هم اصحاب كفاءه عاليه
في يعني كريد سويس في حتى منظمات دوليه ما
هو بس محليه ليش تخسرون هذا الكفاءات ليش
انتم قفلتوا هذا الباب وشايفين احنا ما
خسرناها هذا هو المصطلح لانه ما ودي ان
الناس تنظر له احنا ما خسرنا بالعكس احنا
استفدنا منها اليوم
على مستوى مجلس الاداره مجلس الاداره ترى
مجلس ليش اداره التنفيذيه لانه ابو عبد
الرحمن من يوم ما يدخل احد من العائله
اولا لن تستطيع استقطاب كفاءات اداريه
مستقله اليوم بكل امانه احد اهم
النجاحات اللي حققتها ماسك وقدرتها على
استقطاب كفاءات انا صراحه فخور وكل
المساهمين فخورين بانه يكونوا موجودين
عندنا الحقيقه يعني كفاءات
بحجمهم وما هو كذا بس
[موسيقى]
يعني الرؤساء التنفيذيين اللي قدرنا
نستقطبهم
والمدراء
الاداراتهم يعيشون في بيئه وخلق هالموضوع
بيئه
احترافيه وبيئه مؤسساتيه مئه بالمئه انت
تعرف يا ابو عبد الرحمن مهما كان دخول ابن
من ابناء المؤسسين معك في الاداره ويشتغل
معك في الاداره وفي الليل
عارف انه يتعشى عند دبوبي يسولف والله
اليوم صار كذا وفلان قال كذا وفلان مهما
كان هذا تشيط طبيعي ويصير بياثر على
طموح ان يقود هالشركه
راعي الحلال اكيد المنصب مجهز له هو الاول
يعني
غير طبعا قضايا المنافسه والتنافس اللي
يصير بين ابناء العائله على على هالمنصب
ولا على هالمكان ولا على واللي قد يكون له
تاثيرات يعني كثيره يمكن هذه نجحت معاكم
ابو خالد فانه انا فعلا مبهور وهذه نادره
في في الشركات العاليه من مستوى الكفاءات
التي استخطبتوها الحمد لله يعني نذكر مع
مع التقدير للجميع مثلا معالي الاستاذ
احمد الخطيب كان قبل ما يكون وزير هو كان
كان معكم في تاسيس وقياده شركه جدوى
الى ان تم اختياره في
مستشار في في ديوان سموني العهد الامير
سلمان انذاك في عام 2014 او 2013 ايضا اول
رئيس تنفيذي لشركه ماسك هو معالي احسان
بافقيه اللي هو لاحقا
اختير كرئيس لهيئه عقارات الدوله اليوم
اليقود باسك هو هاني حلواني انت سويتوا
المستحيل على فكره اليوم كل كل قطاع الخاص
يتشكل
الكفاءة يتبول ناس اخذته بالحياه
هو اليوم يقول شركه ماس صحيح فعلا سالفه
انه عدم وجود الابناء ابناء العائله في
الاداره التنفيذيه
اتاح الفرصه انك تستقبل كفاءات بهذا
المستوى مئه بالمئه مئه بالمئه والحمد لله
يعني زي ما تفضلت يعني معالي احمد الخطيب
ترى كان مستشار في تاسيس ماسك
لانه كان هو الرئيس التنفيذي في شركه جدول
للاستثمار وهي شركه مستقله عن ماسك يعني
صحيح في شركه جدوى وفي بنك البلاد
للمستثمر الاكبر
وزي ما تفضلت يعني ما علي احسان بفقيه كان
له دور صراحه كبير في
الفتره الانتقاليه الاولى والتاسيس يعني
يعني
يعتبر ترى يعني فرد من افراد العائله بكل
امانه يعني وعصر الوالد الله يرحمه سمع من
الوالد اشياء كثيره
وزي ما تفضلت اليوم صراحه انا فخور جدا
بوجود رئيس تنفيذي مثل الاخ هاني حلواني
على راس الهرم التنفيذي في شركه ماسك
واعتقد السبب الاول
لقدرتنا على بناء بيئه جاذبه بهذا الشكل
ابو عبد الرحمن
هو خروج ابناء العائله من العمل
خروج ابناء العائله من العمل التنفيذي
اليومي وليس خروج ابناء العائله وتخليهم
عن الشركه ترى هذا الفرق كبير يجب ان يفهم
خليني اتحدى شوي الفكره هذه ابو خالد
واقول لك في عوائل اخرى مثلا من العوائل
الناجحه واللي عندهم تجربه ايضا تستحق
الاحترام عائله الزامل صحيح وعائله الزامل
العكس الابناء العائله موجودين
وعندهم هم سياسه انه اول خمس سنوات لازم
تعمل برا الشركه العائليه بعدين اذا اثبت
نفسك بره الله يحييك تعال وابدا في السلم
وعندهم اظن قانون انك ما تعمل تحت القطاع
اليقود ابوك او يعني احد من نفس الفرع حق
العائله فتجد انه فلسفتهم انه ما حكى جلدك
مثل ظفرك ما حد بيكون احرص على الحلال من
اصحاب الحلال فهم بالعكس يحفزون ابناء
العائله راح اكسب خبره وتعال اشتغل معانا
لانه ما حد احرص على حلال منك انت فكيف
يعني تشوف نموذج هذا
والله يا اخي يبدو لي عائله الزامل جاي من
المريخ
ما اعرف انا ما ادري شلون ههه
ما شاء الله
ههه الله يحفظهم تراهم من اقرب الناس
للعائله ويعني الله يحفظهم وفعلا نموذجهم
نموذج انا شخصيا تسالني اقول انا ماني
عارف كيف نجح بس يبدو ان في ثقافه عاليه
جدا بين افراد العائله في مجموعه الزامل
في قضيه كيف التعامل في حالات
الخلافات والشد شيء
حنا الناس طبيعيين هم هم طبيعيين احنا
الناس الطبيعيه
طبيعي انه انه اي نقاش يتم ويكون فيه شد
لا
بد مع الزمن
الزمن طبيعيين انا ما ادري شو بيسوون يعني
علمني
فاول عنصر صرفنا عنه الان في موضوع ميثاق
العائله انكم منعتوا ابناء الاسره بكاملهم
من العمل التنفيذي اليومي وركزت وجودهم في
مجالس الاداره اللي هو العمل الاستراتيجي
طويل مجالس الاداره واللجان ومجالس ادارات
الشركات ترى هذه عدد كبير من المناصب
ويحتاج الى تخصصات كثيره ويحتاج الى
التزام كبير ويحتاج الى دعم صراحه
اذا تسمح لي بعطيك وش اللي صار عندنا
وفاجئني انا شخصيا يا ريت
واذا تسمح لي عاد هذا الله يستر
لا ان شاء الله ان المصلحه العامه يعني
جزاه الله خير وخليني اخذ
ايش اللي صار عندنا في جيل المستقبل
وامسك كل واحد من استبعد اذا تسمح لي
للعيال لان العيال وابنائهم
قلت لك انا يعني انا وابراهيم وناصر وانا
اولادنا دائما تعرف نسولف عليهم في البزنس
وكذا وندخلهم
فامرهم ماشيه كويس يعني الحمد لله كلهم
يعني
ماشيين على طريق البزنس كذا لكن شو اللي
صار في الجانب البنات
اختي لولوه الكبيره الله يحفظها ويطول
عمرها
صار عندها حفيدات
سووا كان سبت اسمه مليح قبل حوالي شهر
ونجح نجاح باهر وكنسلت عباره عن فاشن
واكسسوارات وصراحه يعني
ابدعوا في في في هالمجال
وضموا
الخواتم واخوانهم معهم في العمل هذا
بالاضافه الى انه بعض الابناء وصلوا
لوظائف كبيره في بنوك في مؤسسات ماليه
ابنائها واحفادها
نمسك اختي هدى اختي هدى ما شاء الله صار
عندها
حفيدات تخصصه في مجالات معينه في التصميم
وبداوا يتاسون مكاتب وشركات في التصميم
وابنائها الان بدي استون شركات استثماريه
تكرر وترسخ وتعيد تجربه ماسك
اختي هيفاء
ام عبد الرحمن
ما شاء الله تبارك الله
تقلد مناصب كبيره واخذوا طريقهم في
يعني العمل في القطاع الخاص في مؤسسات
مرموقه في العالم وما شاء الله تبارك الله
يعني وصلوا لمراحل المتقدمه والان
بدو يعسون شركه استثماريه خاصه فيهم
ولازلوا كلهم هذول اللي يتكلم عنهم تراهم
نزلوا معنا في ماسك وفي المجالس الاداره
وفي الشركات
اختي وفاء
واحد من ابنائها ما شاء الله منصب كبير في
احد القطاعات
الحكوميه المرتبطه بالرؤيه هي التصنيع
العسكري
قامي وما شاء الله تبارك الله ابدع فيها
المجال
وعلى فكره وكان في فتره من فترات عظمة
اداره معنا في في ماسك
اختي مها
ما شاء الله
عيالها دخلوا في قطاع المطاعم ودخلوا في
قطاع
التصميم ووحده من بناتها ما شاء الله
تبارك الله صارت متخصصه في تصميم الاوتفيت
حق المطاعم وابدعت في هالمجال والان عندها
يعني
الاخت ندى
احد ابنائها
كان ايضا موظف في احد البنوك
ووصل لمراحل جدا متقدمه والان في البلاد
طبعا لا لا لا ممنوع لا لا
يعني احنا دائما ما نقبل ما نقبل هذا احد
المعايير اللي قلت لك موجوده في الميثاق
ما نقبل انه يعمل في عمل
له علاقه في ماسك
يعني هذا هذه السنوات اللي يعملها في اي
شركه من الشركات اللي ماسك مستثمره فيها
ما نعتبرها من ضمن السنوات
الان ما شاء الله يعني
ابنها مشعل الموسى هذا اختي ندى يحضر
الماجستير
وبدا ياسس شركه استثماريه عقاريه وما شاء
الله ابدع في بعض الكونسبت وبعض المنتجات
اللي بدا يسويها
على فكره ترى قبل ثلاث ايام مشعل العرب
تجربه ماسك في
مشروع
التخرج في الماجستير
يجلس في جامعه مرموقه في بريطانيا
وكان
بقيه الطلبه عرضوا ونماذج من من مختلف
العالم وابشرك يعني أخذ نموذج ماسك هو
اللي اخذ تقريبا اعلى الدرجات في البرنامج
فعلا كان الحمد لله شهاده نعتز فيها يعني
وهذا الكلام قبل يومين ترى بس
لو اقول لك مثلا احفاد اخوي ابراهيم
حفيدات اخوي ابراهيم شوف البنات
اسسوا شركه
في صناعه الهويه
الان دخلها
فوق الستين سبعين مليون في السنه
اقول لك انتشر في لما سوينا هالكلام بدل
ما يكون كل الناس معتمدين على ماسك كل
ابناء جنوا مستقبل معتمدين على ماسك
وينظرون لماسك ويبحثون عن فرص وظيفيه اللي
ماسك صاروا ينظرون لانفسهم مش اقدر اسوي
وكيف اقدر اصنع قصه نجاح لنفسي هذا المكسب
منهم هذا المكسب
في مواقع اخرى
مذهله تبي الصدق ما كان في الدور للشركه
في هذا الموضوع
يعني ما كان في دور يذكر يمكن مش ساهمت
الشركه العاليه في اول وظيفه
توصيه
يعني توجيه معين دوره معينه مثلا الشركه
العاليه كان
بس هو شاهد هنا بانه يعني لو كله موجودين
في الشركه العاليه يمكن ما طلعت النجاح
بالشكل هذا والقصص النجاح هذه اللي قاعدين
نشوفها ما كان طلعت وهنا بستكمل هذه ابو
خالد واقول لك في موضوع جالس الاداره انتم
عندكم شرط وجود اعضاء مستقلين اظن ثلاثه
من مقاعد عنده تسعه اعضاء نعم حنا مجلس
اداره تسعه ثلاثه منهم لازم يكونون
مستقلين
اشرح لنا مفهوم الاعضاء المستقلين
دور الرئيسي لاعضاء المستقلين
هو الحقيقه
نقل تجارب
وتحدي بعض القواعد الاساسيه الروتينيه
اللي تعودت العائله لانها تعمل
بها يعني
وهذا تعرف الان صار من افضل الممارسات
العالميه ما هو بس عندنا في ماسك اعتقد
هيئه سوق المال تفرض هذا الموضوع وزاره
التجاره يعني تنصح كبير كثير بهذا الموضوع
يعني بكل امانه وجود كفاءات في اي او
كفاءات مستقله تفكيرها يكون مستقل وخارج
العائله في اي مجلس اداره يعطي عده فوائد
الفائده الاولى
يكون
صوت مرجح في حاله انه صار فيه عده اراء في
الاعضاء المجلس الاداره من العائله وحده
الفائده الثانيه
يعطيك راي مستقل في اللي تقول الاداره
التنفيذيه
وراي قد يكون يعني
مشبع بخبرات وتجارب خارج التجارب اللي
العائله
يعني تعمل فيها
طبعا هذا بخلاف الثالث اللي هو اللي هو
فعلا التنوع الخبرات اللي تقدر تستقطبها
اليوم اذا عندك مجلس اداره معظمه مثلا
استثماريين وانت تتخطط انك تدخل في القطاع
الطبي مثلا تقدر تستقطر احد عنده هالتجربه
هذه انت تبغى تدخل في قطاع السياحه
والعائله تاريخيا ما كان عندها
خبرات في السياحه انت تقدر تستقطب احد في
هالمجال وهكذا بكل امانه تجربتنا نحن في
ماسك في دخول الاعضاء المستقلين بحقيقه
كانت تجربه رائعه صراحه جدا ومفيده ويمكن
برضو امتداد لموضوع الاداره وعلاقه
العائله بالاداره اسولف انا مع هاني
حلواني رئيس شركه ماسك وقال لي اول ما جيت
استغربت بانه
يعني توقعت انه هذه ترتيبات عائليه اجتمع
وقالوا هذا الاسماء انا يلا هذا البورد
مثل ما يحدث اغلب شركات العائليه يقول
ذهلت انه ثلاث المقاعد المخصصه للجيل
الجيل المستقبل يتنافس عليها تسعه من
ابناء الاسره ففي منافسه في يعني سباق على
هذا المقعد ما هو بشيء مطبوخ ومرتب
في النهايه مو ببناء الابناء يعني من اصل
ثلاثه اثنين
بنات بنت واحده وبنت واحده يعني هذا ما
شاء الله
المساهمين فعلا
فاشرح لنا كيف موضوع العلاقه المجالس هذه
بالعائله اقصد اشتراطات الترشيح طريقه
التنافس انتوا كنتوا حاطين ثلاث مقاعد
محفوظه مخصصه لكم انتم يا الجيل الثاني
الحين لغيتوها صارت نعتبر قاعد مكتوبه
قاعده الان صارت ممثله للعائله
وصراحه وصار فيه يعني تشجيع كبير من دخول
الابناء جيل المستقبل
في مجالس الادارات
وهنا التوازن اللي نتكلم عنه ابو عبد
الرحمن يعني احنا نشترط مثلا
شهاده جامعيه
نشترط طبعا مجموعه قيم اللي اشترتها قبل
انها تكون متناسبه مع قيم العائله ورؤيه
الشركه العائليه هذه اشتراطات
نشتري زي ما قلت لك خمس سنوات خبره
في شركه مستقله
بعيده عن ماسك وشركه لازم تكون يعني من
الشركه المعتبره شركات المعتبره بنظره
مجلس الاداره و جمعيه المساهمين وايضا ان
يحقق ترقيتين على الاقل خلال خمس سنوات
هذه وفي تفاصيل اخرى يمكن
يعني موجوده ومكتوبه
وفي الميثاق
وهذا اللي يخلي
المرشح يستطيع ان يرشح نفسه
لاي مقعد من مقاعد مجلس التصويت من جميع
الاعضاء لجميع العموميه وانا اقول لك يعني
الصراحه
اللي صعق هاني واللي خلا هاني وهذا شيء
فخوري فيه انا اذكره لانه فعلا
ترى كثير احيانا تكتب افضل عوائل كثيره
كتبت موثيق كثيره لما يجي التطبيق
تجي ابغى استثني هذا وابغى اسوي هذا وهذا
ما اقدر التزم فيه واتنازل عن هذا
[موسيقى]
تصويت سري
كل مساهم ممكن يختار اللي العضو اللي
يشوفه مناسب والاصلح بدون اي ضغوطات
اجتماعيه ولا يقول لا يزل علي اخوي ولا
اختي ولا كانت تصويت بهالشكل وفعلا تم
اختيار ابنين من من بنت وحده وفعلا هذا
الشيء هاني كان يفتخر فيه واحنا نفتخر فيه
يمكن هذا كله جزء مرتبط بموضوع الاداره
وقد نرجع لها في وقت لاحق لكن ابغى اروح
الحين لموضوع الملكيه لفت نظري وانا اقرا
الميثاق انكم اشتركتوا كل الورثه او
الملاك انهم ما يكونون يملكون باسمهم
الكفرات كل واحد حول حصته الى الشركه ففي
شركه اسمها شركه عبد العزيز بن محمد
السبيعي هي اللي تملك في ماسك ليش ممنوع
الافراد يملكون في ماسك وممنوع الاوقاف
يملكون في ماسك
هذا موضوعي صراحه جدا
وصراحه في ممارسات كثيره
وفي خيارات كثيره وهنا صراحه لازم يعني
اشيد
بكل امانه
يعني نظام الشركات السعودي الجديد اللي
طرح
وحرص معالي الوزير الدكتور ماجد القصبي
صراحه
يعني سماع الكثير من ملاحظات الشركات
العائليه انا من خلال دوري في مركز الوطن
المشاتل عليه اشياء كان لنا صراحه دور
كبير في صياغه نظام الشركات السعودي
الجديد وانا بكل امانه
ازعم بانه الحمد لله صار عندنا نظام شركات
باذن الله انه من افضل عشر انظمه في
العالم
وخصوصا من ناحيه المرونه ومن ناحيه
استيعابه لمتطلبات الشركات العائليه
ويبقى قضيه التنفيذ الان واللوائح
التنفيذيه والعمل عليها لكن كنظام عام
اعتقد النظام الشركات السعودي جديد يعني
نظام رائع وداعم كبير للشركات العائليه
احنا لما فكرنا في هالهيكل
كان
بالنظام القديم
ولكن يعتقد صراحه انه هيكل مناسب حتى في
النظام الجديد لسبب ثقافي يمكن اكثر وله
علاقه بالسعوديه احنا عندنا الشركه
القابضه اللي هو الشركه اللي هي ماسك
الملكيه فيها في شركات ذات مسؤوليه محدوده
ونفكر الحين انا نحولها لشركات
مساهمه مبسطه حسب النظام الجديد وهذا
مصطلح وشركه نوع من انواع الشركات اللي مو
موجود في كل الدول العالم
علشان نحمي
الشركه من الورثه في المستقبل لا سمح الله
صار اي خلاف
بين ابنائي او ابناء اي مساهم اخر في
المستقبل في اي موضوع
ففيه الشركات هذه
طبقه عازله بين الخلافات اللي تصير فوق
وبين فاللي كان يصير اول بانه لو مثلا عمر
يملك في هذه الشركه
لو انتقلت حصه عمر الى ابناءه ولا ورثه
فجاه انتم تلاقون بدل ما مالك سبعه ملاك
بالضبط بدل ما تاخذ القرار من شخص واحد
تاخذه من سبعه اختلفوا وعطلوا مصالح
الشركه طبعا الحمد لله لانه شركه مساهمه
مقفله ما تعطل اوكي بس بتسوي شوشره بتسوي
يعني تعرف عدم راحه خلني اقول خلق بيئه
غير صحيه ولكن عمر ومشاكله كلها صارت
محفوظه بالضبط وقبيلكم مع عمر هو مدير هذا
الشريف ممثل ممثل الشركه الممثل في جمعيه
المساهمين فمهما صار التغييرات بين عمر
وعيالي
جايبين لكم واحد وممثلهم واحد مئه بالمئه
اوكي هذا هدف الاول جميل الهدف الثاني
هو
في قضايا البيع والتخارج والرهن احنا ما
نبي يكون كل واحد عنده يروح يرهنها في بنك
وياخذ مقابلها وكذا وتتفاجا بكره انه في
بنك دخل شريك معك بنك دخل شريك معك فهذه
ايضا طبقه عازله انت لك حق تتصرف في اسهمك
اللي فوق بس الاسهم اللي تملك مباشره في
الشركه العائليه
وعلى فكره الشركات هذه ليس المساهمين الحق
في التصرف فيها في اي عمل خاص يخصهم او
الهدف منها فقط تملك اسهم شركه القابضه
اللي هي شركه شركات ذات غرض محدد شركه لا
تغرض محدده نعم وهذه طبقتينها ناجحه هذه
طبقت وانا انصح فيها بكل قوه صراحه في كل
الشركات العائليه يعني انا انا اشوف انه
يعني
خلق هذه الطبقه العازله
يعني خلق بيئه في اجتماعات لجمعيه
المساهمين ابو عبد الرحمن تشوفها اليوم
كانك في اي شركه مدرجه
خلني اتكلم عن الموضوع الاوقاف
تدخل في هذه الشركات احنا الحقيقه
ولا زلنا يعني لا زلنا الى اليوم
يعني نظام الاوقاف يعني
بحد ذاته او فكره الاوقاف بحد ذاتها فكره
مختلفه شوي عن الشركات العائليه فكره
تعتمد على
اختلاف يمكن جوهري في الرؤيه ولذلك هي
خطيره صراحه ودخول الاوقاف في الشركات
العائليه يجب ان صراحه يدرس بشكل معمق وما
اخفيك لا لازلنا الى اليوم ما وجدنا حلها
الموضوع
في بوادر حل
لكن فعلا دخول الاوقاف بشكل مباشر في اي
شركه عائليه
انا اعتقد انه يعني
وصفه
لحدوث مشاكل في
قلت لك رؤيه الاوقاف تعتمد على
توزيع ارباح بشكل
اكثر
تعتمد على عدم اخذ مخاطر
نظار في الاوقاف دائما لابسين طاقيه
المدافع بينما الشركه العائليه مهاجمين
اللي
يبون يعظمون المنفعه فيصير فيه دائما
اشكاليات في في قضايا المخاطر واخذ
المخاطر والتوسعات والتوزيعات وكذا في في
اختلاف جوهري في الرؤيه فلذلك انا انا
انصح انه صراحه ما يكون الدخول الاوقاف
دخول مباشر
صراحه ايضا اكرر نظام الشركات الجديد
[موسيقى]
اعطى بوادر كبيره صراحه لحل هالموضوع احد
اهم الادوات اللي اعطاها هو وجود
اسهم متعدده
يعني اسهم ممتازه واسهم عاديه
من خلال استخدام هذه الاسهم تقدر يعني
تحط اسهم بدون تصويت
اسهم تستحق الى توزيعات اعلى واي شروط
تقدر تحطها في هذه الانواع المتعدده من
الاسهم بما يساهم ان شاء الله في المستقبل
بانه يعني يحلها الاشكاليه احنا منتظرين
اليوم ونشوف ان شاء الله كيف نقدر
نستخدمها الادوات هذه في حل مشكله الاوقاف
باذن الله يمكن واحده من اكبر المعضلات
الشركات العائليه واللي تؤدي الى انهيارها
هو موضوع التخرج
هذا ورث انتقل من المؤسس الى الورثه الى
الابناء البنات واحد منهم يبغى يكمل يبغى
ياخذ فلوسه كاش بيطلع فعاده يصير اما انهم
يجبرون يقعد وهذا يعني زي ما انت تضرب
المثال تقول اذا سكرت قفلت الباب حديت
الواحد يكسر القزاز ويكسر القزاز او انه
يصفي كل الشركه عشان ياخذ حقوقه ياخذ حصته
كيف تعاملتم مع موضوع التخارجه اللي لاحظت
انه هذا فصل واضح في الميثاق ومكتوب
الاليات وحتى في ديسكاونت او خصم معين
عطنا كيف تعاملتوا مع موضوع التخارج وفي
حاله اظن صارت لو ممكن تسولف هالله هالله
صحيح
يعني فعلا زي ما ذكرت ابو عبد الرحمن
اعتقد التخرج من اهم
المسببات اللي تسبب تشنج
وتعطل اعمال الشركات العائليه وسبب في
كثير من الاشكاليات اللي تعاني منها
بطبيعه الانسان وبطبيعه البشر ابو عبد
الرحمن تختلف
احتياجاته ورغباته ومع اختلافه في السن
وفي
الخبره وفي العمر وفي العلاقات بين الاسره
يعني سواء ذكر او انثى
ولابد ان
الشركات العائليه والعوائل ياخذوا هذا في
الاعتبار في اي تنظيم او اي هيكلات تعمل
لانه لو ما اخذته في الاعتبار
وسكرت الابواب
وما صار في طريق واضح
للتخارج وكيف تقدر تحصل على قيمه ثروتك او
قيمه
مساهمتك
راح تسبب مشاكل زي ما قلت اذا الباب مسكر
حتك ترى تكسر الشباك وتطلع من الشباك وهذا
يسبب يعني مشاكل
احنا اتبعنا اسلوب انه فعلا الحريه موجوده
اليوم لاي مساهم يبغى يطلع من الشركه
العاليه
عملنا اجراءات محدده في الميثاق
في تقييم سنوي يعمل
اسهم شركه
فيه
خصم يعطى وهذا زي اي خصم يعطى لاي شركه
مملوكه من
شركه خاصه غير مدرجه مملوكه من المساهمين
خارج السوق الماليه
يسمونها
وايضا عملنا حقوق اولويه للمساهمين اللي
موجودين يعني اليوم حط الشفه حق تعاملنا
مع حق الشفعه هذا باجراءات محدده واضحه
يعني اي مساهمه اليوم يبغى يبيع
في الحق الاول
للمساهمين من الفرع
اللي هو فيه
هم اللي
يعني لهم الحق الاولويه انهم يشترون هذه
الاسهم
اذا ما في رغبه هناك نطلع للدائره اوسع من
المساهمين والافراد العائله
يصير لهم
ايضا حق وحق حسب نسبه ملكيه كل واحد في
الشركه
وبعدين اذا باقي شيء نرجع للي عندهم
الرغبه ياخذوا حصه اكبر من حصص ملكيتهم في
الشركه
وعملنا شيء ايضا وهذا صراحه يعني
يعني اعتقد انه ايضا مهم انه
الشركه في النهايه اذا اذا ما كان في رغبه
في شراء اسهم من عند اي من المساهمين ان
الشركه العائليه نفسها لها الحق انها
تتملك اسهمها بما لا يتجاوز عشره بالمئه
حسب نظام الشركات
يعني بهالطريقه هذه صراحه عملنا تنظيم
لقضيه التخارج اعتقد انه
مطمئن للمساهمين وياخذ في الاعتبار مصالح
ايضا الشركه المساهمه بالاخصها انا اليوم
انا عمر املك في ماسك اللي بيصير باني اول
شيء اذا قررت اني اتخرج هذا الحق محفوظ لي
ومتاح وميسر مئه بالمئه فاجي اقول ابغى
ابيع حصه اللي تساوي مليون ريال انتم عطوه
تخصمون منها 20%
فابي احدث مئه الف
مخاطر بقاء الاسهم معهم فهذا هو الخصم حق
التقييم اللي المفروض انه بشكل عادل اول
ناس لهم حق يشترون هالحصه حقتي الف ريال
هم الفرع القريبين مني بالضبط اخوانك
وخواتك اللي موجودين اذا ما كان في احد
منهم يرغب تروح للعائله للعائله الاكبر
كلهم بحسب حصته نعم وبعدين اذا ما تغطت
ففي اللي يبغى ياخذ حصه اكثر بالضبط يتاح
له اخر خيار انه اذا ما تغطت حتى من
العائله الشركه تقدر تشتري هذه الاسهم
وتكون اسهم شركه او اسهم خزينه
بحيث انه ما تطلع الحصص من العائله ولا
يمنع هذا الشخص اللي يبغى يغادر انه يغادر
وصارت الحاله هذه لو تعطينا اياها والحمد
لله صارت نعم في احد المساهمين الحقيقه زي
ما قلت لك الرغبات يعني
بتختلف من شخص لشخص كان يبغى يوقف ويبغى
يسوي وقف عمل خيري خارج الشركه
والوقف تعرف كان غير غير متاح
يعني باع جزء من الاسهم
بنفس الاجراءات اللي ذكرتها قبل شوي
وتمت العمليه بكل سهوله وبكل سلاسه
والصراحه اللي شيء اثلج صدورنا كلنا ابو
عبد الرحمن
وهذه ارجع واكررها
وافتخر فيها انه اللي اشتروا الاسهم هم
البنات
وهذا يدلك كيف الشفافيه وسحر الشفافيه
والوضوح والحوكمه كيف خلا
التزام البنات تجاهها يعني الشركه
العائليه نتكلم في موضوع البنات
والشفافيه
ودي نقفل هذا المحور بقصه اول جمعيه
عموميه
الله يحفظها الله يطول عمرك لما لما
دعيتها الجمعيه والله فعلا هذا ترى زي ما
قلت لك مشكله ثقافيه منها كثير من العوائل
السعوديه ترى
يعني قضيه الثقه بين البنات والاولاد وانه
انا لا اذا جيت وحضرت
وتابعت ودققت
اشكك في اخواني هذا صراحه شيء كان من
اوائل الاشياء اللي لاحظناها والحمد لله
اهتمينا فيها
وقدرنا انها فعلا نكسر هالحاجز هذا وقصه
اختي لولو الله يحفظها ويطول عمرها كان في
اول جمعيه عموميه كنا بنوقع فيها الميثاق
فقلت لها لازم تجين قالت لا ماني بجايه
شلون اجي وش تبون اجي الشركه العائليه
وقاعد تشرح لها وذكرت لها جدول الاعمال
كان مكتوب فيه
الاداره كانت وشو أنا تبيني اخوانك انت
صاحي انا واثقه فيكم
يلا يلا روح بس
بعطيكم وكاله جيب لي ورقه بس اعطيك وكاله
وانتم مسوين تبون كذا قلت لها اذا ما جيتي
انت ترى الموضوع كله بيخرب وترى بينهد
وترى انا ماني محاضر قالت ما علي منك رح
بكيفك انا تسويه ماني قلت لها ترى بجيب
بمر عليك وباخذك بالسياره انت وجيبي معك
واحد من العيال
وفعلا تكلمنا مع بناتها تكلمنا مع عيالها
اقنعوها لازم تجي ما اقتنعت الا لما قلنا
له جيبي واحد من العيال الله يحفظه نبيل
جامعها واقنعها يعني
تجي وفعلا اول ما جت كانت يعني الجمعيه
الاولى هذه عباره عن يعني خلني اقول لك
زلزال يمكن نقاش اللي شافوه والشفافيه
اللي شافوها وجبنا الرئيس التنفيذي
وعمل تقرير مجلس اداره وجبنا المراجع
الخارجي وموجود وكان اي واحد يقدر يسال
واعضاء المجلس الاداره المستقلين كانوا
موجودين ابو عبد الرحمن فكانت
اول مره يتعرضون لشيء زي كذا ويبدو لي ان
شاء الله انه هذا هو السبب الاساسي في
الالتزام والابداع اللي تشوفه اليوم الحمد
لله من البنات بالتحديد في دعمهم للشركه
العائليه يمكن هذا الرحله الطويله ابو
خالد من الحوكمه والمؤسسه والشغل
الواحد يقول هل تشفى ولا ما تسوى هل تفرق
ولا ما تفرق خلاص عطني حصتي نطلع نمشي لكن
اللي فهمت انا انه كل هذا اللي صار وهذا
الجهد اثمر اول شيء بتماسك العائله كعائله
في نمو الاصول ونمو ثروه العائله وفي
استمرار العمل الخيري اللي كان والدكم
يحبه ويبغى يتوسع فيه بل بالعكس انتم
تتوسعون فيه وفي ترتيب المكتب العائلي
وحنسولف الحين على موضوع العمل خير مكتب
العائلي بس ابغى يعني اتجرا واسالك واقول
كم فرقه ثروتكم بعد الحوكمه ههه
والله شوف يا ابو عبد الرحمن صدقا يعني
هذه الاسئله التي بتخليني تبي تخلي اخواني
واخواتي يطردوني من الشركه العائليه
ترى هذا الجهد يعتبرها مصاريف زايده اضافي
والله ما هي مثاليه لكن صدقا الرقم ما
يفرق يعني ما ابغى اقول لك الرقم لانه
فعلا الرقم اصوله من هذا الرقم الى هذا
الرقم ما هو فرق تجد وين الفرق يا ابو عبد
الرحمن الفرق في جوده هذا النمو اللي تحقق
الفرق في هذه هذا المحرك اللي صنعناه
الحمد لله
واستدامته والى اي مدى يقدر ياخذنا
انا اقول لك من 2010 الى اليوم تضاعفت
الثروه ثلاث مرات ثلاث مرات ثلاث مرات
الحمد لله ما شاء الله تبارك الله ولكن مو
هذا هو المهم المهم زي ما تفضلت
العلاقه الاسريه نمت وصارت يعني
بين كاخوان وحتى ابناء جيل المستقبل ابشرك
علاقه جدا نظيفه ورائعه وبعيده عن تعرف
لما يكون وسخ الدنيا
والشيء الثاني
دعم الاسره للشركه وتفهمهم اللي ما يحدث
فيها والشفافيه والوضوح
الشيء الثالث
زي ما قلت لك قدرتنا على استقطاب الكفاءات
هذا خلى عندنا هذا المحرك
اللي اللي له القدره اليوم انه يصنع
الفارق مو لنا عائله الاقتصاد الوطني
دخلنا في مجالات اليوم ابو عبد الرحمن ما
كنا نحلم ندخل فيها
وحدتنا الحمد لله نجاحات في قطاعات وانت
ما شاء الله يعني احد المراجع في الرؤيه
استطعنا ندخل في القطاعات انا ما كنت افهم
فيها ولا احد من المساهمين كان يفهم فيها
هذا الميزه والفرق لو انا قسمت الثروه انا
بشتغل بالشيء اللي ارتاح له لان اولا اولا
انا صار حجمي صغير فما اقدر اخذ مخاطر
عاليه لكن اذا
اجتمعنا كنا
مجموعه وعائله وعندنا رؤيه واحده واستطعنا
نبني فريق عمل محترف
قدرتنا على الدخول في مجالات
قدره اكبر قدرتنا على التعامل مع الدورات
الاقتصاديه والمخاطر والتعامل معها بشكل
اكبر
قدرتنا على
تحقيق العوائد
والاستثمارات والارباح ولو هالحلال ما
تقسم وتوزع اهم من هذا كله قبل
ايضا قدرتنا على
عمل مشاريع المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه في
الشركه اكبر
وعمل
ودعم المؤسسه الخيريه المؤسسه غروس
الخيريه ايضا اسسناها الوالد والوالد الله
يرحمهم واحنا معاهم بشكل اكبر
فهذا كله يصب فيه انه الرقم يا ابو عبد
الرحمن ما هو مهم
النسبه انه فعلا فيه هذا الحراك كله ادى
الى انه هذه ثروه تتماسك وانها تتضاعف
تتعظم ولو هي مقسمه قطعا ما حيقدر انت
تجيب عبد العزيز ولا ابو خالد هاني حلواني
يدير ثروتك لكن لانها بهذا الحجم تقدر
تجيب كفاءه بهذا المستوى وتعطيه حوافز
مقسمه على على عشره اخوان لكنك انت لحالك
تتحملها وما حقدر تدخل في القطاعات
المتنوعه اللي دخلت فيها صحيح وعلى فكره
احنا وحده من الاشياء اللي
انت حكيت عن التنوع جبت كلمه التنوع
ذكرتني في سالفه احنا فشلنا في اننا ننوع
جغرافيا استثماراتنا احنا شركه مستثمره في
السعوديه تاريخيا وبقينا في السعوديه
وحاولنا يعني كان في محاولات خجوله زي ما
قلت لنا نخرج برا السعوديه
ولكن فشلنا فيها صراحه لانه اولا يمكن
تنظيم ما كان عندنا وهذا الان ساعد
الكفاءات ما كانت موجوده انها تحتاج الى
كفاءات مختلفه يقول لك انا
الخروج بره ثقافه العائله صعب بتفشل فيه
اذا نظمت
وكنت متحد وكان عندك الحجم
تستطيع انك تدخل في في قطاعات فل وجود
اليوم
الاداره المحترفه بقياده الاخ هاني حلواني
وبقيه فريق العمل لنفتخر فيهم
ماسك اليوم صنعت اكبر برنامج
سعودي للاستثمار في الشركات الناشئه في
العالم
احنا نستثمر في كل دول العالم وهذا اول
مره نطلع برا السعوديه بشكل بحجم كبير
فاستطعنا ان الصراحه يعني نطلق برنامج
باذن الله احنا فخورين فيه ونتوقع ان شاء
الله انه بيكون من افضل البرامج
للاستثماريه والمستدامه للاستثمار في قطاع
الشركات الناشئه والتقنيه
والقطاعات الحديثه يضاف لجدوى شركه جدوى
وبنك البلاد موضوع فجر كابيتال موضوع
الارجان للتطوير العقاري موضوع طبعا قبلهم
كلهم الشركه الوطنيه للسزراعه المائي اللي
هي نجوى
وكذلك
المرافق يعني الملفت لما تابع هذا
الاستثمارات احس انكم موازين
توجهات الرؤيه وملفات الرؤيه فالاستزراع
السمكي اليوم من احد اهم الملفات وحتى
مبروك ما شاء الله استحوذ على حصه نعم
تستاهلون الله يبارك لكم ماسك في موضوع
لوجستك هذه انطلقت بعد ما اطلقت الرؤيه
وتضح انه احدث ركائزنا هي محور ربط
القارات والتركيز على القطاع هذا نتكلم
على ذاخر مشروع عملاق في اكبر مشاريع قطاع
الخاص في مكه المكرمه بالطريقه اللي تسوي
او تخفف الضغط عن المنطقه المركزيه انتم
قريبين بعيدين ضمن الحدود الحرام بس ما
انتم في جنب الحرم
وبدا البيع في المشروع واللي هو يخدم ضيوف
الرحمن وبرنامج ضيوف الرحمن فابغى اسالك
عن الفرص اللي انتم شايفينها واهم
القطاعات اللي اختلف وضعها بعد اطلاق
الرؤيه وصرتم مركزين عليها او مهتمين فيها
يعني
النمو في في الثروه ما جاء من فراغ ابو
عبد الرحمن انت لما تكون منظم عملك
وتكون مسوي اجراءات وسياسات داخليه في
العمل العائلي تبدع في استغلال وقتك في
التركيز على
النظره طويله الامد وهذه احد اهم فوائد
التنظيم
فعلا صرنا نشوف من فوق وين التوجهات نعطي
راينا
ونعطي قراراتنا وطبعا ونناقش وندخل على
مستوى مجلس الاداره وعلى مستوى الشركات
التابعه
ووجود الاعضاء المستقلين ايضا يضيف الى
جوده النقاش لتحصل على مستوى مجلس الاداره
وهذا اللي انتج الحمد لله نجحات اللي
ذكرتها يا ابو عبد الرحمن بكل امانه ما جت
بسهوله وما جت
بصدفه
جت فعلا بتركيز على يعني
الفرص اللي خلقتها رؤيه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه 2030 بكل امانه واللي انا اشوف
انها يعني
يعني
اعاده عمليه اعاده هيكله ضخمه للاقتصاد
السعودي
نتج عنها وبينتج عنها فرص لن تتكرر انا
اشوف انه يعني حرام ان الشركات العائليه
وارتطاع الخاص بشكل عام ما يستفيد من
تجربه
يعني اعاده الهيكل اللي قاعده تصنعها
الرؤيه اليوم
وهي
شيء ما يحدث لكل 200 300 سنه صراحه في اي
اقتصاد ولا ولا اشوف في اقتصاد في اي دوله
في العالم
حدث فيه ما يحدث عندنا وحجم الفرص وعدد
الفرص
يعني نشوفها كل يوم
ولا نستفيد منها بصراحه وعلى فكره يعني
كثير من الاجانب قاعدين يشوفونها اليوم
فاليوم الفرصه موجوده ولن تكون موجوده
بشكل دائم اتوقع بعد فتره بيكون فيه يعني
التقاط لهذه الفرص هذه من من جهه حتى
خارجيه لفت نظري انه كل الاستثماراتكم او
جله يمكن في استثناء واحد كلها ما انتبه
لحالكم دائما في شريك فبنك البلاد انتم ما
حولتوا يعني من مصرفيتكم لحالكم دخلتو
معاكم ناس صحيح جدوى اسستوها بالشركاء
ذاخر بالشركاء نجوى انتم داخلين انتم
الراجحي مع البلاع
ميم الظاهر دخلت معكم شركه ماليزيه في
اداره المرافق صحيح فما تشتغلون لحالكم
ليش هذه احد القيم ابو عبد الرحمن اللي
ورثناها من الوالد واللي
اليوم الاداره التنفيذيه تشبعت فيها وامنت
فيها والتزمت فيها
فعلا وجود ترى شركاء متعددين يعطيك قوه
ويعطيك حجم في القطاع شوف زي ما تكلمنا
اليوم عن الحجم والقوه في على مستوى
الشركه العائليه
قد ما تقدر تخلق حجم
وتنوع على مستوى القطاع او الشركه
التابعه هذا ايضا يعطيك قدره على انك تسوي
مشروع اكبر وتتحمل مخاطر اكبر نفس الكلام
اللي كررناه في الشركه العائليه ووحده
الشركه العائليه نكره حتى في
[موسيقى]
اسلوب عملنا في الشركات التابعه
واستقطاب خبرات اليوم اليوم القطاعات كلها
اغلب القطاعات الرؤيه زي ما تفضلت تراها
جديده على كثير من العاملين في السعوديه
اليوم فالطريقه الوحيده انك تشارك اللي
على الاقل عنده تجربه وعنده خبره
وامانه الفريق التنفيذي في شركه ماسك
اليوم
مؤمن بهذه الرؤيه وقاعد يطبقها بشكل يعني
كبير اليوم في كل استثماراتنا ايضا نسال
الاستقطاب يعني شركاء المهم في هذه النقطه
هذه انك تستقبل الشريك الصحيح الشريك اللي
يؤمن معك بنفس الرؤيه عنده نفس الثقافه
عنده نفس القيم هذه تراها مهمه جدا
انا كنت في بحر الاحمر قبل قبل ايام قليله
وسولفوا لي عن جمعيه خيريه جديده
وقالوا من شركائنا السبيعي
طبعا عارف القصه وانت شرحت لي اياها بس
اللي ما اعرف هناك انتم ليش كتبتوا
السبيعي يعني في جمعيات خيريه في البلد
مهوله كانوا هم من القلائل اللي لقيناهم
عندهم نموذج الاستثمار في الشركات الرياده
الاجتماعيه او او الاثر الاجتماعي
فهذا مدخل جيد نوضح كيف اثر تنظيم الشركه
العائليه خدمكم بانكم تعظمون وتواصلون
العمل خيري اللي والدكم الله يرحمه كان
محب له بل كتب في وصيته انه اتمنى ان
تستمرون عليه وتحببون احفادي في العمل
الخيري
وش صار في موضوع العمل الخيري او العمل
الغير ربحي
احنا الحقيقه يعني
انطلاقه من
صك الوالد الوصيه والوقف اللي اللي ذكرت
ونظرا لتغيره ايضا الظروف وصراحه التطور
الكبير في التشريعات والانظمه اللي
ايضا المملكه العربيه السعوديه يعني
قامت بها
وجدنا انه من المهم
ان العمل الخيري يتنظم
واستخدمنا نفس التكنيك والتقنيات والافكار
اللي نظمنا فيها شركه العائليه في تنظيم
العمل الخيري
واسسنا مؤسسه خيريه اسمه مؤسسه غروس مؤسسه
محمد ابراهيم السبيعي واولاده الخيريه
وحبينا ان يعني تكون مؤسسه مختلفه شفنا
وين
القاب اللي موجود في العمل الخيري وين وين
القطاعات اللي ما هي مغطاه
وحاولنا نغطيها في رؤيتنا لتاسيس هذه
المؤسسه
واحد اهم يعني الثغرات اللي وجدناها
واستثمار الاجتماعي
المفهوم الاستثمار الاجتماعي اليوم هو
مفهوم متطور في العالم
وحبينا يعني
نستفيد منه ونجيبه ونطبقه في السعوديه
لانه يخلق عمل خيري
ذو اثر
ومستدام هذه معادله بكل امانه
تعظم وتدين
والاثر في اي عمل تقوم فيه والحمد لله
وحده من الافكار ولا الافكار اللي صراحه
طلعت فيها المؤسسه
هي تاسيس جمعيه زراعيه تعاونيه في البحر
الاحمر
تكون مسؤوله عن
تطوير المزارع الافراد
ومساعدتهم في اهم قضيه من القضايا ابو عبد
الرحمن انت تعرف ما شاء الله عندنا يعني
جوده منتجات رائعه ترى في السعوديه تحدث
في التسويق التحدي في التسويق والتحدي في
التدريب على استخدام التقنيات الحديثه في
الزراعه هذا الاثنين حتكون الجمعيه هذه
باذن الله الرائده في تغطيتها
يعني الحقيقه بدعم ايضا من برامج الرؤيه
واحد اهم برامج الرؤيه وشركات صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه لشركه البحر الاحمر
استطعنا استطاع الجمعيه هذه التوقيع
اتفاقيه مع البحر الاحمر اتفاقيه اوفتك
حتشتري من المزارع اللي هناك باذن الله
اول ما تنطلق الفنادق هناك وتفتح يعني
ابوابها
وحيكون المحتوى المحلي موجود في مشترياتها
وبدانا اليوم نتعامل مع المزارع العوائل
اللي يشتغلون فيها اهل المنطقه هناك حصلت
اكثر من الالف مزرعه حصلنا اكثر من الف
مزرعه ما تتخيل كيف
المزارع المانجا مزارع التمور مزارع
الفواكه والخضروات شيء رائع ابو عبد
الرحمن ولكن يحتاج الى شويه يعني افكار
فبناخذ المنتجات ونساعدهم واتفقنا على
معادله وهذا اللي يقول لك الاصدام الماليه
من وين جت اتفقنا مع المزارع على معادله
انه اي ربح اضافي يتحقق لك من تطبيق
افكار التسويق والافكار التدريب والتقنيات
الجديده اللي تستخدمها
حيكون لك المزارع والجمعيه هذه حتاخذ بس
عشرين الى 30% لتغطيه مصروفاتها
وعملنا معهم طريقه بانه كل ما طبقت تقنيات
اكثر كل ما زادت هذه النسبه عندك اكثر كل
ما اعطيتنا المنتج بجوده افضل جوده افضل
ترى بتزيد الجمعيه هذه دورها حاجتين رقم
واحد انها تاهل المزارعين لاستخدام
التقنيات الزراعي الحديثه كفاءتهم ورقم
اثنين انها تشتري وتسوق المنتجاتهم
وحق المزارع محفوظ سعر تكلفته هذه مضمونه
له وفوق كذا اي ربح يحققه الاغلب له 80%
20% لهذه الجمعيه عكس اللي حاصل اليوم
اليوم الوسيط اللي هم عاده من عمال او
جامعه يجي يشتري المحصول بتراب الفلوس
بالمزارع ويروح يبيعوا في السوق ماخذ
الهامش الاكبر هذا الوسيط اللي في النص
انت واليوم قلبتوها صار الهامش الاكبر
قاعد يروح للمزارع اللي تعب الرزق وصنع
القيمه وانتم تاخذون جزء الاقل كجمعيه
لضمان استدامه عملكم صحيح اليوم شوف سلسله
الامداد في القطاع الزراعي المزارع اكثر
واحد ياخذ مخاطر واكثر واحد يبذل الجهد
واكثر اكثر واحد
واقل واحد ياخذ ربح صحيح تلقاه في النهايه
يبسط قدام مزرعته ولا يسوي له محل ولا كذا
او يجي اللي هم الوسطة زي ما تفضلت شريطيه
حقين ويشترون
المحصول حقه وفي خلال يوم او يومين يحققون
اللي يحققوا
الاضعاف المزارع في الموسم كامل سواء ثلاث
شهور شهرين وهو يزرع ويتعب تلقى الوسيط
يحصل
دور الجمعيه التعاونيه هو
انها بتكون تحل محلها الوسيط هذا وتكون
ممكن للمزارع
في ايصال منتجات الزراعيه بشكل صحيح وهذا
النموذج اللي كانت تفتقد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من زمان انا اذكر يعني في
مبادرات كثيره صارت من الدوله صحيح على
حلها الاشكاليه ولكنها ما انحلت ليش لانها
كانت تخلق الافكار كلها كانت مبنيه على
انك تخلق شركه بطبيعتها ربحيه ولازم تعظم
ربحها هذه لاول مره
يكون الوسيط هو عباره عن جمعيه تعاونيه
وليست شركه ربحيه تجربه ثانيه رائعه جدا
وهذه انا حبيت فيها نفس المبدا انه في
تحدي او في مشكله تدخلون بنموذج مالي
مستدام وتحلون التحدي موضوع
الهدر الغذائي السعوديه من اعلى معدلات
الغذائي وهذا من فضل الله وكثر نعمته صار
الهدر هائل جدا وهو شيء مؤلم والكل يبغى
يتعامل معاه بس ما في الى الان حل عملي
انتم دخلتوا باستثمار في دوم
لتدوير الخبز قصه رهيبه وحتى نهايتها
ملفته او مو نهايتها اللي وصلتوا له اليوم
ملفتا لسه القصه لها تكمله ان شاء الله
ايضا مؤسسه غروس الخيريه وجدت
احد رواد العمل الخيري
كان عنده يعني شغف وحب في العمل الخيري
وكان يشتغل في احد الجمعيات وجد انه
الناس دائما تلقى الخبز معلق على الخبز
بالتحديد يعني ما يعرف ليش يعني في حاجز
نفسي انك ترمي الخبز في في النفايات يعني
فدائما تلقى الخبز معلق ففكر وقال يعني
كيف اقدر احلها المشكله هذه واخدم يعني
العاملين
الناس في في كيف يحافظون على هالنعمه
فراح جاب السلات خبز
بجهد شخصي في البدايه وصار يوزعها بمقابل
بسعر رمزي على البيوت
وهذه السلات مصنوعه بشكل معين بحيث انها
تجفف الخبز
يعني ما تسبب تلفو
وياخذها يمر ياخذها منهم في نهايه كل
اسبوع ولا شيء يكون خبز مجفف ويستفيد منها
في الاعلاف وفي الاسمده وفي يبيعها يبيعها
اوكي يبيعها نعم
هو اول بدايه لا ما كان يبيعها البدايات
كان يروح يعطيها بس مجرد عمل خيري كان
وفعلا لما بدا يسوي هالشيء هذا
اشتغل هو واولاده وبناته وفي هذا الموضوع
وجد انه في طريقه انه يقدر يخلي العمل
مستدام
في انه اولا يبيع
المنتج هذا اللي هو الخبز الجاف وثانيا
وجد شيء غريب ان الناس عنده استعداد تدفع
مقابل السله مع انه من اول كان يوزعها
مجانا قال انه عليك عشان تريح ضمير عشان
تريح ضميري
فهنا جاء هو بحث عن مستثمرين لانه الموضوع
يحتاج الان الى راس مال ويحتاج الى
فاكتشفت غروس الموضوع هذا ودخلت معاه في
شراكه عمل استثمار اجتماعي وعامل خيري
ولكنهم يعتمد على قواعد الاستثمار فسويت
شركه هو
وعائلته طبعا يملكون الحصه فيه ودخلت غروس
وبعض افراد العائله ايضا من عندنا دخلوا
مساهمين في هالشركه هذه
وفعلا بدات تمارس العمل بشكل منظم اكثر
وبشكل محوكم اكثر وما تتخيل كيف توسع
اليوم والطلب سوينا مواقع على يعني موقع
الانترنت والتواصل الاجتماعي والان في طور
التطبيق بنسوي تطبيق لهالموضوع بحيث انك
تطلب بشكل الكتروني السله
ويمكن نتعاقد مع شركات التوصيل اللي
موجوده نموذج عمل المتطور جدا
ومستدام في اداره هدر الخبز الان ويمكن ان
شاء الله نتوسع بعدين الى الى يعني
منتجات اخرى غير اليوم من الشركه عندها
يعني تتفقات نقديه موجبه ما شاء الله شركه
اليوم عندها تدفقات نقديه وعندها نمو
صراحه مهول واحنا ما بدينا الا بس
بالرياضه متوقعين نطلع ان شاء الله لمدن
اخرى ودول اخرى ابشرك جتنا طلب من بعض
الدول في المنطقه اننا نعيد التجربه هناك
وهذا دائما يؤكد انه الحل اذا جاء باسس
يعني اسس الاعمال او الاسس التجاريه
ولو اثر اجتماعي هذه الوصفه السحريه لحل
عميق ومستدام ما حيوقف بكره لانه الداعم
ين او الممولين بيوقفون
يربح ههه
سمعتنا يا ابو عبد الرحمن
لا لا ما في بس في مسجد في مسجد مستدام صح
ولا لا ههه
ههه
[موسيقى]
نخلق نموذج عمل يكون
قادر على انه يصرف المسجد بنفسه على نفسه
اليوم ابو عبد الرحمن تشوف وضع المساجد
هذا الشيء مؤسف صراحه في السعوديه
وتقارنوا مثلا باللي موجود في دول اخرى
اسلاميه
تجد المساجد عندنا مبنيه بشكل ما ياخذ في
الاعتبار معايير
الاستدامه ولا ياخذ حتى
كفاءه الكفاءه التشغيليه ولا الهدر وتلقى
المسجد هدر في المساحه وهدر في المال وهدر
في الطاقه وهدر في المياه
وقس عليها
فكان صراحه الفكره ان نخلق نموذج يعالج
هذه المشاكل كلها
والحقيقه يعني بدانا اول نموذج
مسجد معمور في الرياض
واستطعنا الان فقر طبعا
والحقيقه المسجد يعني حذف بدعم بصراحه
جميع الجهات الحكوميه يعني مشكوره من
وزاره الشؤون الاسلاميه الى وزاره الشؤون
البلديه والقريه وحصل صراحه على لانه فعلا
كان نموذج جديد يعني دخلنا بعض الفراغات
في المسجد بطريقه تخدم اهل الحي بشكل
ممتاز اخذنا نماذج في توفير الطاقه
وفي توفير المياه وعملنا حدائق اضاءه
طبيعيه
عملنا
يعني بالنسبه
للارصفه والحركه
تاخذ في الاعتبار لعاقه البصريه
وتاخذ في الاعتبار العاقل الحركيه
الاعاقه السمعيه ايضا في وقت الاذان
المناره تتحول الى لون مختلف بحيث انه
يشوفها اللي عنده يعاقه سمعيه ويعرف انه
هذا اذان بدا الان وقت الصلاه ايضا نفس
الشيء فلوقات العاديه يكون فيه النور
الابيض العادي مثلا
طاقه شمسيه
اعتقد وصلوا الان الى 25% من استهلاك
الكهرباء
تدويرها او استخدام الاستخدام الحدائق
وصلنا لمئه بالمئه مئه بالمئه
المدوره وانتو سويتوا حركه في موضوع
فراغات المسجد عاده او او مساجدنا يعني
للاسف هذا التبخم صف الاول هو اللي مليان
لا مو بالصف الاول
تلقاه مصمم المسجد بشكل كبير
عشان مثلا صلاه الجمعه ولا صلاه الاعياد
ولا كذا فتلقى في الفروض العاديه دائما
يرجعون يرجعون وراء فانت تركت اجمل مكان
اللي هو مكان المحراب
والمكان اللي فيه يعني يعني خلق المسجد او
او مميز مميز المسجد فيه
ورحت ترجع وراءه مكان مظلم ما يستخدم الا
مره في الاسبوع بشكل يعني ساعه في الاسبوع
او ساعتين فرحنا في التصميم احنا سوينا لا
انه خلينا المكان اللي هو الرئيسي في
المسجد اللي هو مكان المحراب والمنبر هو
المكان اللي صلى فيه يوميا وحولنا
الفراغات الاخرى الى فراغات متعدده
الاستخدامات المسجد صار فيه روضه اطفال
صار في صيدليه وصار فيه
بقاله وصار فيه جهاز صرف الي او صراف
وهذه كلها وقاعه متعدده استخدامات اظن
استخدامات
للحي نعم
الزواج واللقاء الاسبوعي لاهل الحي وكذا
ومعايدات وكذا ولكن كل هذه تقدر تستغلها
في الفراغ الفراغ زي هذا تقدر تستغله
روضه الاطفال تقدر تستغلها في الصلوات في
اوقات الذروه فعكسنا المعادله فانت اليوم
تصلي في يوميا في احسن مكان
وفي الايام اللي تحتاج فيه الى عدد مصلين
اكبر تقدر تفتح الفراغات هذه على الفراغ
الرئيسي وتستفيد منها وهذا الصيدليه او
الروضه والبقاله والصراف كلهم مستاجرين من
الشركه المالكه للمسجد نعم شركه وقفيه على
شركه عشان
هي شركه وقفيه هذا الايرادات غطت مصاريف
المسجد نعم ابشرك تحت اشرافائض تحت اشراف
وزاره الشؤون الاسلاميه
والجهات الاخرى ويعني الحقيقه اللي لها
علاقه كلهم الحقيقه
استطعنا الحصول على دعم كبير دعم دعم
تنظيم حليت مشاكل المسجد ووفرتوا خدمات
لاهل الحي صحيح وحسنت تجربه المصلي جدا
اليوم الروضه عليها قائمه انتظار
واللي يشغلها شركه سعوديه وشباب سعوديين
البقاله واحده من اهل الحي امراه من اهل
الحي هي اللي ماسكه البقاله وهي اللي
تشغلها وابشرك يعني حققت ارباح واليوم
قاعده تفكر تفتح بقاله ثانيه بره ما شاء
الله ما شاء الله
الصيدليه كذلك سبحان الله الصيدليه لانها
موجوده في المسجد صار في ارتباط عاطفي
تعرف المريض احيانا يعني يسعى لانه ياخذ
يعني
الجانب النفسي في الموضوع فصار يشتري
الادويه من الصيدليه هذه ما يروح يشتريها
من مكان اخر واقرب طبعا
ونفس الشيء الصراف
وجدنا انه الاطفال صاروا يجون للمكان هذا
لانه الشباب يجون المكان هذا لانه صار
مكان فن يعني مكان جميل وهو طالع ياخذ له
شيء من البقاله ولا هو داخل ياخذ له كوفي
ولا شيء ولا صار في ارتباط اهل الحي
بالمسجد والفعاليات اللي فيه طبعا
ايضا شيء ثاني
البرامج اللي موجوده في المسجد استطعنا
تطوير برامج مثلا مع جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
برامج الرعايه الاوليه والاسعافات الاوليه
برامج مع جهات كثير
تعليميه وتثقيفيه
صراحه كان فعلا تجربه وفكره رائده لربط
اهل الحي بالمسجد واعاده فكره المسجد زي
ما كان في صدر الاسلام مركز
لاجتماع الناس
وتلاقي الناس والتعلم
يعني عمل اشياء مفيده للناس ويمكن هذه
تؤكد انه مفهوم الاستدامه دائما تاتي
مصلحته للجميع بس اللي الملفت هنا انه رغم
نجاح التجربه من كل النواحي ما تكررت سويت
واحد وقفته لابشرك كيف لا لا ابشرك هو كان
في تحدي صراحه زي ما قلت لك بفهم
التشريعات والتنظيمات والحمد لله هو انت
تخلق نموذج اول بعدين تحاول تغير يعني او
تاخذ في الاعتبار
التشريعات اللي موجوده لانه كان في تخوفات
من النموذج هذا واحنا كنا صراحه ما احنا
واثقين في نجاحها بصراحه فقلنا خلنا نسوي
النموذج ونتاكد فدائما النموذج الاول ياخذ
وقت بس ابشرك الان
الشركه الوقفيه شركه المساجد المتكامله
اسمها ابشرك اليوم عندها طلب كبير في
اعاده التجربه هذه مساجد في مساجد اخرى
وفي متبرعين كثير صاروا يتواصلون
يعني مع الشركه لتكرار هذا النموذج في
احياء كثيره سواء في الرياض او خارج
الرياض وابشرك بشره اخرى انه جتنا طلبات
حتى من دول اخرى في المنطقه
جتنا من مصر جتنا من الامارات جتنا من
الاردن
طلبات لاعاده النموذج هذا وخلقه هناك الله
يقويكم انا بختم بتجربه ايضا رهيبه لانها
تؤكد مفهوم غروس
كمؤسسه
تركز على على رياده الاعمال الاجتماعيه
وعلى الاثر المستدامه ابغاك
تحكي لي قصتكم مع وتين مع انه ما هو
بمشروعكم ولكن الاحتكاك معكم ادى الى تحول
جوهري في البشر وش صار
وتين هو صراحه مشروع رائد كان اسس من قبل
مجموعه شباب السعوديين يمكن تعرف اغلبهم
والنعم فيك وفي التبرع بالدم واداره
التبرع بالدم وبدات كعمل خيري
وصراحه لقت كثير من الدعم والرعايات ولانه
فعلا كانت
وتحولت مع الوقت الى نموذج لاداره بنوك
الدم في السعوديه
كثير من المستشفيات صارت
لوتين
العمل في بنوك الدم ونقل الدم من مستشفى
الى مستشفى ومن المدينه الى بحسب الاحتياج
وتخصصه في هذا المجال
بس لازال النموذجهم كان يعتمد على
التبرعات كان كل ثلاث سنوات يوقعون عقد مع
شركه ترعى التطبيق هذا وياخذون منها يعني
مبلغ مقابل الرعايه
الله يذكرهم بالخير جونا هنا في ماسك وقال
نبغى ماسك من ضمن مسؤوليه الاجتماعيه انها
ترعى التطبيق
اول شيء صراحه صدمناهم فيه قلنا لهم طيب
ما عندنا مانع بس نبغى تعطونا نموذج
استدامه للفلوس اللي بنعطيكم اياها انتم
ما تحتاجون اليوم تصرفون على شيء ما شاء
الله تبارك الله يعني اموركم بدات تتحسن
وكذا بس نبغى فلوس هذه نعطيكم اياها
تعطونا وشلون انت بتستخدمونها علشان
توصلون لي التوازن المالي والاستدامه
الماليه
فانصدموا صراحه من الطلب هذا زعلوا علينا
شوي قالوا كيف تتشرطون علينا قلنا هذا
الشرط تبون ولا
الله يذكرهم بالخير صراحه
تقبلوا الفكره
وتقبلوا التحدي فعلا كان تحدي وهذه هذي
يعني صراحه عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]
قد كثير من الناس ينظرون لهالموضوع النظره
ماديه بحته والله واحنا ترى
هو فعلا
محاوله انت قلتها اول كلمه استخدام تقنيات
وادوات العمل الاستثماري في العمل الخيري
وفي العمل العائلي حتى
سالفه المطبخ
الله يجزاهم خير قبل يعني فتره جونا
وصراحه يعني
طلبوا اجتماع زملاء في وتين
وبداوا جزاكم الله خير انتم في بطلبكم هذا
اللي زعلنا اول شيء
صراحه فتح لنا افاقنا ومداركنا لاشياء
وقرارات سويناها
وتسببت اليوم وكانت سبب اليوم في انه
الحمد لله وتين يصير ما هو بس
مستدام ماليا صار مربح ما شاء الله ابشرك
يعني صار مربح ومطلوب من دول اخرى واعتقد
انهم راحوا للكويت الان وراحوا للبحرين
وراحوا لدول كثيره
يعني هذا ايضا دليل على انه فعلا
تطبيق مبادئ الاستثمار الاجتماعي
اللي مطبق في دول كثير سابقتنا في العمل
الخيري يجب ان نتبناه بشكل كبير وبشكل
اسرع اسرع عشان ما نظلم تجربه ودي اختم
فيها العمل الخيري ثم انتقل لي اخر جزء في
حلقتنا موضوع
مالي تطبيق مالي انتم ايضا مواكبين الرؤيه
واولوياتها بما يخدم ثقافتكم ونشاطكم
الرئيسي ككيان استثماري انت اشتغلتوا على
موضوع زياده الوعي المالي وزياده ثقافه
الادخار والاستثمار عند الاطفال لو تحدثنا
عن تطبيق مالي والاثر اللي حققه
بحكم
الوالد الرجل مالي الله يغفرله ويرحمه كان
دائما
يدربنا على كيف استخدام المال
والتصرف فيه والاولويات
طلعنا بالعائله الحقيقه اسست ايضا مؤسسه
وقفيه اسمها
وهذه بعيده عن صراحه ماسك كانت بجهد من
افراد العائله انفسهم
وكان اول
يعني هدف ميم عين هو
معالجه بعض الاشكاليات التعليميه عند
الاطفال
ومساعده برامج التعليم العام في الوصول
لاهداف الرؤيه فيما يتعلق بزياده الوعي
وحمايه الاطفال ورفع مستوى التعليم فكانت
متخصصه في هالمجال اول برنامج اطلقناه وهو
برنامج مالي برنامج مالي هو متخصص بزياده
الوعي المالي والثقافه الماليه والاقتصاد
السلوكي لدى الاطفال
ويعني
هو عباره البرنامج مكون من لعبه الكترونيه
ولعبه وراقيه وقصص
مجموعه مع بعض
تطبق في بيئه معينه للاطفال في المدرسه او
في احد المراكز او المجتمعات
وتساهم في رفع الوعي المالي عند عند الطفل
وتعريفه بالمصطلحات الاستثمار الادخار
تحديد الاولويات
عشان ايضا نخلق النموذج عمل مستدام يعني
وجدنا انه فيه في برامج الرؤيه
اهداف معينه موجوده اليوم على القطاع
البنكي
وتحت مظله البنك المركزي
وحاولنا ان نخلق
او نبني او نضمن هذه الاداه في البرنامج
التثقيفي للاطفال ونجحنا ابشرك الحمد لله
في اننا مو نستقطب فقط
البنك المركزي والبنوك السعوديه في في دعم
هذا البرنامج بل حتى بعض برامج الامم
المتحده
جهات ايضا
اخرى تعنى بالتعليم في العالم لما شافوا
النموذج وقيموه وجدوا ان النموذج صراحه
فريد من نوعه في العالم فانك كيف تستخدم
التلعيب او اللعبه
بدون ما يحس الطفل في انه يجمع مصطلحات
ويرفع مستوى ثقافته الماليه 50 الف حتى
الان ولا لا نعم صحيح ما شاء الى الان
يعني بدعم البنك المركزي السعودي الحقيقه
يعني باذن الله متوقع اننا
نصل الى برنامج اوسع واشمل على مستوى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وباذن الله حينطلق قريبا برنامج يعني واسع
في هذا المجال وقابلت انا بندر العامر
اللي ماسك الموضوع وقال لي قديش حاطين
عليه اهداف انه يتحول ايضا للاستدامه
الماليه نبعد وصل لها لكنكم يعني فوق راسه
لين يستدين ماليا صحيح لا ابشرك ان شاء
الله يعني في كثير من البنوك السعوديه
اليوم ترغب ايضا في انها تحط مثلا من ضمن
اللعبه
تحط مثلا اعلاناتها حساباتها المعينه بعض
الاشياء اللي في في افكار ان شاء الله
ممتاز انا يعني ودي اختم باخر جزء واللي
ما حنطول فيه احتراما لخصوصيه العائله
ولكن هو ركن اساسي في التنظ بعض الاشخاص
يعتقد انه يتنظم الشركه العائليه وحط هذه
الضوابط انه يخسر امتيازات او يفقد بعض
المكتسبات والعائله هي الاساس هي الركن
الاساسي في كل القصه هذي كلها فكثير
العوائل يعني عندها املاك مشتركه او منازل
او او مزارع او مرافق تجمع هذه العائله
ومناسبات
يعني اجتماعيه لهذه العائله فانتم ايضا
هذا الترتيب والتنظيم والحوكمه اثروا
الايجابي يمتد الى حتى شؤون اسريه وشؤون
عائليه بانكم حافظتوا على كثير من الاشياء
اللي كانت ممكن تفقد او او تضيع لو فككت
التركه او الورثه وانتهت التنظيمات ومن
ضمنها المطبخ المركزي اللي صار فيها ربح
الحين كل شيء تحول الربح لا يا ابو عبد
الرحمن
الله يبارك الله يبارك فيكم بس حدثني عن
المكتب العائله كيف قدرتوا انتوا ايضا
تضيفون ضمن هالقصه
احد اهم الاركان الاساسيه اللي الميثاق
غطاها يمكن ما تطرقنا لها هو مكتب العائله
زي ما قلنا ميثاق يتكلم عن
الاداره والشركه العائليه
ولكنه يتكلم عن العائله فزي ما تفضلت
في في بندين في الميثاق لهم علاقه
بالعائله واقل علاقه بالعمل العائله
والشركه العائليه اللي هم مجلس العائله
ومكتب العائله
مجلس العائله هو
المظله التي تجمع العائله بالكامل سواء
كانوا مساهمين في الشركه او غير مساهميه
في الشركه وهذه لها تنظيم ولجنه وعمل
وبرامج متخصصه بس لدعم العائله وتجمع
العائله والتقائها
وبعض المبادرات الاجتماعيه
والخيريه ما يتعلق بالعائله
مكتب العائله
هو عباره عن مكتب يقدم خدماته للمساهمين
من افراد العائله
وبالذات المساهمين اللي ما هم داخلين في
العمل
التجاري يعني ما هم في اعضاء مجلس اداره
ما هم في
وجد انه دائما في خدمات معينه يستفيد منها
جزء من المساهمين اللي اشتروا في الشركه
اللي يشتغلون في الشركه واللي ما يشتغلون
في الشركه محرومين منها فمن باب تحقيق
العداله
وخلق فعلا قيمه مضافه زي ما تفضلت
ودعم لافراد العائله سواء كانوا ممارسين
للعمل او غير ممارسين وجد مجموعه من
الخدمات
وخلقنا هذا المكتب او اسسنا هذا المكتب
وتشرف عليه اللجنه من المساهمين
لتقديم خدماته
للمساهمين فيما يتعلق فيه امورهم الشخصيه
سواء كانت
تامين طبي
وسواء كانت اعمال سكرتاريه حجوزات حجوزات
سفر
واعمال المراجعات الحكوميه او التعقيب
واعمال مثلا البرامج
الصيفيه اعمال مثلا العماله المنزليه
وايضا احنا كان عندنا اشياء مشتركه باقيه
لا زالت مشتركه باسم
المساهمين مع بعض زي ما تفضلت فيه استراحه
في بيت مثلا
موجود في مطبخ هذا يخص كل المجموعه كل
المساهمين ما يخص فرد وما فيك ترى كثير من
المشاكل تجي من الاشياء المشتركه اذا
الاشياء المشتركه ما نظمت اولا يجب ان
تكون اقل ما يمكن الاشياء المشتركه صراحه
يجب ان تكون اقل ما يمكن ولكن هي لابد
منها صراحه وجودها يزيد ترابط
واذا وجدت لازم تتنظم بشكل صحيح
فالهدف كان من مكتب العائله فعلا انه يقدم
خدماته في الملكيات المشتركه وفي تقديم
الخدمات للافراد من افراد العائله
المساهمين فيما يتعلق باشياءهم الشخصيه
طبعا في اشياء ما يقدمها وهذه نقطه مهمه
امور مثلا الشركات او البزنس الخاص في كل
واحد هذا شانك شان خاص ففيه خطوط حمراء
وخدمات محدده بالتحديد يقدمها المكتب ولا
ولا يتوسع في في اكثر من هذا يعني
وعلى فكره ميزانيه ميزانيه المكتب هذا
تدفع من المساهمين ما العلاقه الشركه
الشركه تخصص من الارباح المساء المساهم
بعد ما يجيه الربح احنا متفقين وهذا وهذا
متفق فيه ميثاق العائله
جزء من الارباح يروح لتغطيه جزء بسيط طبعا
يروح لتغطيه مصاريف مكتب العائله وكان
وقتها يجيك انت اتصالات عن البقدونس
[ضحك]
ربطه البقدونس وبقفل
شوف عبد الرحمن صراحه يعني لانه مثال حلو
على كيف تنظم وتطبق نفس الثقافه في ثقافه
قاعده تطبقونها في شركتكم التجاريه
وتطبقونها في عملكم خيري وتطبقونه حتى في
شؤونكم الاسريه فبس نبي قصه البقدونس
والمطبخ وبعدها وعدت اقف في الموضوع
شوف في اشياء كثير الله يغفر الوالد كان
له مثل يقول
مليون في دربه ولا ريال في غير دربه
يعني
حتى لو كانت بسيطه تافهه بس تفتحلك
اشكال وتفتحلك ثقافه غلط
نرجع لقصه البقدونس او ربطه البقدونس
انا كان لي صديق عزيز وكنت او كان عزيزي
يمكن الحين بعد بعد القصه دي صار يكلمني
ما عاد يبغاني كنت جالس انا وياه ونتكلم
في فعلا كان في فرصه استثماريه طارحها
ويبغاني ادخل معاه في في الشركه وكنت
منغمس معاه في حوار مهم واجتماع مهم وفجاه
انا قعدتها في الاجتماعات حط التليفون على
الصامت يعني بس لقيت يعني فجاه اتصالات من
المسؤول عن المطبخ عندنا الشيف اللي موجود
في المطبخ وما رديت عليه بس لقيت غير
العاده يعني اتصال خمسه سته سبعه انا قلت
حريق ولا شيء ولا الله يستر فاستاذنت من
صديق العزيز وقلت له خلني برد على
المكالمه ورديت ولقيت انه يكلمني انا سوى
لي جرد اليوم فلهذا ولقيت في فرق ربطتين
بقدونس ههه وانا والله العظيم اني ما هذا
وكان اخر يوم في الشهر ولازم علشان ياخذ
مكافاته ولا زم لازم يحل يلقى حل مشكله
البقدونس
فانا قلت له ربطه البقدونس هذه طيب وش
تاكد وين لقيت رابط البقدونس
وقاعد وقاعد يتكلم عن ربطتين بقدونس
خلاص الموضوع ابدا طبق النظام اللي موجود
عندك وابدا ابشر ما في مشكله اذا كان
الموضوع ربطتين بقدونس
حطيت السماعه خوية
في ربطتين بقدونس يوم حطيت لا والله
الموضوع كذا قال لا لا لا لا
الحين زعلان علي طبعا
[ضحك]
وبعدها بديت الشغل على المطبخ وش اللي صار
فعلا مطبخ البيت
اسسناه بطريقه بدل ما كان اول مركز تكلفه
ويمكن ابو عبد الرحمن انت تعرف كثير من
العوائل موضوع المطبخ والشراكه فيه هذا
مشكله كانت تكلفه بس مجرد ندفع تكاليف ولا
ندري وش يصير فيه ندفع رواتب العاملين
وندفع المشتريات وكذا ونتوزعها وبس
وجدنا فيها هدر وجدنا فيه عدم عداله وجدنا
فيه جوده منخفضه ووجدنا فيه ازعاج بصراحه
يعني
فمكتب العائله اخذ على عاتقه بتوجيه من
المساهمين صراحه وفكره كانت طرحت من مكتب
العائله نبي ننظم المطبخ ونحوله من مركز
تكلفه الى مركز ربح
ولا الربح معناته استدامه ناخذ فلوس نبي
نغطي تكاليفه بس
وطبقنا عليه فعلا مبادئ التجاريه التجاريه
اللي يطبقها اي اوتيل اي فندق في مطبخه
المركزي رفعنا مستوى الخدمه عملنا منيو
وعملنا اسعار واخذنا في الاعتبار ان
الاسعار هذه تكون اقل من السوق بحيث انها
ما تغطي بس التكلفه ما يصير فيها ربح
نظمنا العمل حطينا سياسات واجراءات للطلب
للمشتريات
للموارد البشريه
حطينا سياسه مكافات وهذه الله يهديه الشيخ
اللي فشلني راعي البقدونس
وجدنا انه صراحه الطاقه الانتاجيه زادت
الطلبات زادت رضا
العائله صراحه بشكل كامل زادت بشكل كبير
صار في ضغط انهم يا جماعه طيب نبي نطلب
صديقي الفلاني
يبغى يفتحها برا وخصوصا انه تصادف هذا في
فتره الوالده الله يغفر له ويرحمها وشاركت
في وضع
الوصفه لكل طبق من الاطباق فصار في وصفه
خاصه للبيت
ما تتخيل كيف صارت تجينا الضغوط انه
افتحوا لنا ارسلوا لنا وبندفع فلوس تكفون
ما يخالف فاضطرينا فعلا نفتح لبعض
الاصدقاء
والحين والحين ابشرك ربحان
ربحي ومن فكره المطبخ اسسنا شركه كيترنج
الان برا
اسمها يرشف وسوينا لها براندم سوينا لها
كذا
وابشرك الان بدات تاخذ يعني دورها في
تقديم الخدمات اللي عاشة
لشركات كبيره وبنوك كبيره
واسر في مناسبات زواج او يعني مناسبات
اعياد واحتفالات النقطه الاساسيه انه لو
الاداره التنفيذيه خارقه في التشغيل او
الافراد العائله الغارقين في التنفيذ
والتشغيل والعب اليوم يمكن ما كان عندهم
الوقت
لتفكير باشياء الاخرى وتنظيمها وترتيبها
واستقطاب المختصين في كل جانب صحيح
وهذي من بركات الحوكمه والتنظيم
والتركيز افراد العائله على ادوار غير
الادوار التشغيليه انا بختم بسؤال وهو حلو
انه يكون في الختام لانه يلخص يمكن القصه
كلها لما لما جيت تتحدث معك الله يسلمك عن
عن فرصه استثماريه كنت تقول لي انه لازم
نستاذن من الشركه العائليه مع انه هذا كان
استثمار خاص لك انت واللي
ولكنك ذكرت وبعدين انا طلعت عليها في
الميثاق شفتها الشركه الام لها الاولويه
في اي استثمار يجي الافراد العائله تروح
للشركه الام اولا نعم اذا الشركه الام ما
تبيه او او مستغني عنه وقتها يحقق تدخل
ولازم تفصح للشركه الام عن استثمارك حتى
ما يكون في تعارض مصالح او بعدين انت
ربطتها بموضوع الميثاق
اهميه تحديد رؤيه للشركه العائليه بحيث
انه اي استثمار ضمن رؤيتها ممنوع انتهى
الفرد تدخل فيه لو نختم اللقاء بموضوع
رؤيه الشركه العائليه وتعرضها مع
استثمارات الافراد صحيح
من اهم مبادئ الحوكمه ابو عبد الرحمن هو
معالجه قضيه تضرر المصالح واليوم تشوف
نظام الشركات السعودي ونظام شركات في اي
دوله ونظام هيئه السوق الماليه
بتركيز كبير على انه فعلا شفافيه ونزاهه
وضوح
التعامل والاطراف ذوي العلاقه
هذا الموضوع اذا ما ضبط
يعني راح يدخلك في
اشكاليات تضارب المصالح اللي تكلمت عنها
ففعلا احنا عندنا
اي عضو
يرشح ليكون عضو مجلس اداره
طبعا الميثاق فصل بين الاعضاء اللي في
مجلس الاداره والاعضاء اللي خارج مجلس
الاداره العضو اللي خارج مجلس الاداره
له الحق يمارس اعمال واستثمارات
ويعني
تاسيس شركات بشكل اكبر واوسع ونطاق اوسع
يعني المحظور الوحيد عليه هو انه ينافس
يعني ما تدخل في قطاع ينافس الشركه
العائليه انت كمساهم
تطلع في كل سنه على تغيير الاداره وتقرير
الشركه وتعرف المجالات
فيجب عليك ما تنافسها واذا نافذتها الشركه
لها الحق او جمعيه المساهمين للحق انها
تصوت بانها تشتريه منك هذا العمل
يعني
باسلوب اجراء معين
الاعضاء مجلس الاداره اللي في في المجلس
يحذر عليهم
بالاضافه لهذا الموضوع انهم يؤسسون اي
شركه في اي قطاع
لانه قد يكون قطاع من ضمن اهتمامات الشركه
ولكن لسه ما بعد دخلت فيه
لهم بس الحق في استثمار اموالهم في
الادوات النقديه وفي الاسهم
المتداوله وفي الصناديق
غير الثلاثه هذه اي عضو من عظام مجلس
الاداره يجب ان يفصح عن اي استثمار يبي
يسويه
لمجلس الاداره ومن ثم لجمعيه المساهمين
بالاضافه لهذا الموضوع بعد ما ياخذ
الافصاح
للشركه العائليه الحق في اي وقت انها تجي
وتقول تعال والله انا هذا القطاع عاجبني
وانت بدات شركتك فيه ابغى استحوذ عليها
وبشتريها منك شراء
يعني بتقييم
يعني باسلوب تجاري بحته
فبصراحه هذا الموضوع
ساهم في
زياده الثقه وهنا اللي اتكلم
كيف البنات الاخوات زادوا حصصهم اشتروا
كيف الشفافيه والوضوح والثقه
والكنترول اللي على الاطراف التعاملات
الاطراف ذوي العلاقه وزاد في
بناء البيئه بيئه الشركه ابو عبد الرحمن
اليوم واستقطاب الكفاءات اللي تكلمنا عنها
لولا وجدها الاشياء هذه لما جو ولا ولا
الممارسات المعروفه والشركات العاليه انه
يجي الاخوه اللي له سلطه ولا له صوت
يسوي للشركات مع الشركه العائليه اي مدير
تنفيذي نزيه ما حيقبل مارسات صحيح
والاخوان طبعا اللي ما استفادوا من هذا
الاجراء اكيد انهم يشعرون بانه
كل جمعيه عموميه سنويا تستعرضون كل الفرص
اللي ينوي الشخص يدخل فيها نعم
ويوافق توافق عليها الجمعيه انك تدخل ولا
لا بالنسبه للعظام الاستداره تعرض على
مجلس الاداره اولا بعدين تعرض على الشركه
اولا وتبدا الشركه رغبتها ولا لا في
البدايه بالاساس بعدين اذا قالت شركه انا
ما ابغى
تعرض على مجلس اداره لانه قد يكون فيه
توجه استر توجه استراتيجي مجلس الاداره
يوافق عليها بعدين ترفع للجميع العموميه
لاخذ انا استمتعت بالحوار جدا ابو خالد
ودي اني اختمه طال عمرك
بوصفه مختصره يعني لو الواحد اليوم سمع
الحلقه هذه واقتنع بانه يحتاج ينطلق من
نقطه معينه لو تلخص لنا توصيتك بعد هذه
التجربه لهذا المستمع اللي يبغى يؤسس
مبادئ الحوكمه
وترتيبات الشركات العائليه في شركتهم وش
بتنصحك
اذا تسمح لي بس ارجع واتكلم شوي عن
يعني بيئه الشركات العائليه السعوديه
وتاريخها شوي يعني في الخلافات فيما يتعلق
في الخلافات
انا اذكر يعني بشكل واضح
يعني وزي ما أشوفك اتهامي كيف الملك سلمان
الله يحفظه ويطول عمره من يوم ما كان امير
منطقه الرياض الين صار ولي عهد كيف كان
يتدخل شخصيا في حل كثير من الاشكالات
بالشركات العاديه صحيح
الامير محمد ولي العهد الله يطول عمره
بالمبادرات اللي خلقها اليوم واعاده
الهيكله والتنظيمات والتشريعات حط في
اعتبارها الكلام هذا
بشكل واضح يعني
سمول عهد انا اعرف انه
في تواصل مع وزاره التجاره ومعالي الدكتور
ماجد القصبي
اللي فعلا دعم الشركات العائليه ومحاوله
الحد من الهدر الناتج من التفكك والخلافات
اللي انا اقوله احنا اليوم
في بيئه
يعني غير مسبوقه في السعوديه
لخلق كيانات تجاريه
كبيره وشركات عائليه حيكون لها دور مو بس
على مستوى الاقتصادي السعودي على مستوى
الاقتصاد العالمي
وخصوصا مع الفرص اللي حتخلقها رؤيه 2030
ويمكن في تجارب كثير في الدول في كوريا
وفي امريكا وفي اوروبا
شركات عائليه صار لها صيد كبير يعني اليوم
هونداي في كوريا
سامسونج
اللي اللي خلقته واللي سوته هو نتيجه انه
تنظيم العمل العائلي
وخلق والايمان اولا بانه فعلا
الوحده والاتحاد مع بعض والتنظيم
والشفافيه هي الطريق لخلق نجاح بهذا
المستوى
فانا اولا الحقيقه يعني
اعتقد الشركات العائليه السعوديه بحاجه
تنازلات مؤلمه يا ابو عبد الرحمن لازم
تحدث يعني
انك انت كمساهم اليوم تتنازل عن جزء من
حقك
وهو حقك الشرعي والقانوني والنظامي في
سبيل انك تساهم في خلق الكيان حتى قرار لا
يمكن يتخذوا احد وهو عنده ذره شك في شريكه
او في اخوه او في اخته
اللي اقوله انا
ضروره وسرعه تنظيم العمل والبدايه
من الميثاق العالي
واليوم وجد كيانات
يعني في سواء شكينات حكوميه الحقيقه وزاره
التجاره داعمه بشكل كبير لهالموضوع
الله يحفظ الامير محمد داعم وفي في
الديوان الملكي فيك اكثر من جهه الان شغال
على الموضوع مركز الوطن للمنشات العائليه
تم تاسيسه بامر ملكي
وله دور في هالموضوع الغرف التجاريه اليوم
عندها صراحه وعندها يعني ادوات تقدر تساعد
كبير كثير في هالموضوع المطلوب المبادره
باذن الله تعالى ممتن لك ابو خالد وممتل
لاسره السبيعي الكرام على اتاحه التجربه
الخاصه لعموم المستمعين والمشاهدين حتى
يستفيدوا منها وان شاء الله اجرح لكم باذن
الله الله يحفظك شكرا لك واتمنى ان شاء
الله اني اكون
يعني ازعجنا عائله عنده اخواني واخواتي
اتمنى انهم ما يكونوا زعلوا علي
نقول لهم يعني احتسبوا الاجر ان شاء الله
شكرا شكرا لكم شكرا القصير في انتاج
الحلقه ياسر الغانم في اداره التصوير غالب
جنودي في الاضاءه ياسر كدشه مساعد اضاءه
وفي التصوير عبد الرحمن عبود وفي تسجيل
وهندسه الصوت عبد العزيز المزي وفي
التحرير انس الخليل وفي الاشراف على
الانتاج غيداء التميمي واصيل بافرط هذا
بودكاست سقراب احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]